all right and we are live the last word
with Lord Cognito and ebontist a Friday
evening campfire what's going on man
just another regular day no no special
guests right now no active no activity
in the gaming world no community in a
frenzy or anything nothing at all no
nothing we got a lot to talk about but
before we do we have an awesome guest we
tried to get him on before my internet
said no today we say screw you internet
and we're gonna make this happen
all right welcome to the last word
number 136. we have been chosen but we
are not quite sure why the destiny
player base is all in a frenzy and even
though kaito wants us to bend the knee
Zavala has chosen to say F that in Epic
fashion a new season is upon upon us
with lots of new shiny things and who
better to discuss it with than a master
of the destiny Arts a gamer from way
back who started on the 8-Bit systems
like many of us who are no longer spring
chickens a lover of Adventure
Platformers and shooters from the early
days of gaming that recipe could only
lead to one thing you might say it was
his destiny oh this man is already a
band teacher drum Master unconventional
golfer and Tetris Champion but he wanted
more like many of us who started with a
group of friends playing Destiny he is
another one of the last men standing in
his Destiny Circle but there is nothing
wrong with that because his work wasn't
done yet could you get a Flawless trials
card with nothing but a few drum pads he
found out you could is there a record
for the most Zero Hour clears ever he is
that too feeling Unworthy of our guests
as usual let's welcome a man who has
more ascendant Challenge videos than
even I do a member of the fudge Pusher
stream team a lover of birds someone who
knows that floofing doesn't feel right
and that taken King is the best raid the
one the only Mano Destra 777 how are you
doing sir I'm doing wow gee man I I
don't know after that I should go get
the other guy I mean he sounds pretty
good I'm just saying
[Applause]
Hi man what's up guys
I felt so bad last time but now
hopefully the street gods are with us
you know what I'm saying we have a man
in the building about a campfire oh man
I'm excited man how you been doing
otherwise
things are good man it's uh cold up here
in Minnesota uh it's gonna be over the
weekend it's gonna be like a wind chill
of negative 40 and like a low of like
negative 16. so no no I'm not leaving
the house yeah bro we we in Northeast uh
New York New Jersey uh Connecticut right
now we just got like 10 12 inches of
snow and it's been like non-stop snow
all the time but we're like okay I'm
done with this now I'm done shuffling so
that's why it has to be like life for
you
at some point weather-wise but we don't
have that temperature I will say this
you can keep that temperature yep I'll
say I'll do what I can
talk to the folks over here see if we
can keep that over in the slide yeah no
no man but yeah let's get into it man be
obviously
tremendous Destiny stuff we'll get into
and obviously you know what you're doing
as a content creator but about the
journey as far as a gamer man like some
classic classic titles in your history
so Sega later so what I wanted to talk
about that man you guys you got some
Heavy Hitters you discussed
everybody there oh I mean uh I'm here
okay yeah okay it looked like it froze
was like yeah yeah okay see technical
difficulties were weary now so no
your gaming history started like eight
bit with some ones that are obviously
holding pretty goals place to me so like
and also the fact that it's hilarious
you're like oh the first gaming system
in your dad regrets itself ever since
which is amazing so
um just kind of your history through
gaming and what
like what games hooked you as you were
younger and obviously we know you kind
of landed on Destiny's you put
everything together but what are the
main pieces that like what were your
gamer gaming years as you were you know
a wee little one like some of us were
once ever a long time ago sure
um
I mean uh some people call me a little
bit of a boomer but yeah less definitely
like classic NES my I remember my
brother and I were like yo we gotta have
that classic NES yo and we um we really
got into my brother and I really got
into like the Mega Man games
um a whole time I love I I am like
actually my jam like all the Mega Man
games and stuff like that so that was
that was amazing
um I did the Mario thing but like in
Mario who didn't play Mario three right
yeah I mean have you guys ever seen the
13 hours too much yeah yeah do you ever
see the movie The Wizard if you ever get
a chance Lord Cognito knows that one and
it's like Super Mario Brothers 3 and
stuff like that so
um
um I was terrible I was a terrible
brother I annoyed my brother after the
NES I was a horrible terrible brother
and I said we're not getting a Super
Nintendo I want a Sega because I want to
play that stupid blue Hedgehog listen
you went the wrong way man I'm so sorry
no no no let's listen though you you are
a man of culture listen I know this NES
guys yes SNES is like one of the
greatest consoles of course but the man
needed some Genesis he needed some Sega
he needed some speed he needed to blast
some processor he needed to know what
Nintendo
that's right oh my gosh
what an ad campaign absolutely
um so I was terrible and my brother
still gives me a hard time for that we
did get like an SNES later but uh mainly
did that if you've never played there's
a Sega there's a couple of Sega like
just classic games I really enjoyed too
um other than the Sonic games if you
ever get a chance to check out gun star
Heroes oh my Lord that oh my goodness
that is that was like my brother and I's
favorite game because we could both play
it was like kind of like a platform
shooter but um if you if you've played
cuphead
um at any point like I know that's a
weird jump but it's because like they're
very similar games and like a lot of
stuff was inspired from Gunstar Heroes
for that game and that's like one of the
best Sega games if you ever get a chance
to like play it it's an amazing amazing
game
um and then Shining Force is an RPG that
a lot of people don't know about it's
kind of a it's kind of a final
fantasy-ish but it's more linear it's
it's a little explorery and so we like
that but then after that like uh yeah
lots of really good Sega games we did
again an NES eventually and then uh yeah
to the Past on there but I also got to
go back we gotta go back eight bits yeah
Mega Man yep which is my question the
best Mega Man of all time is Mega Man
but three has part of two in it so
therefore It's gotta be better exactly
look at that
I think part of it was too the music
from all the Mega Man games since I'm a
musician like Dr Wiley's theme I find it
on Spotify every so often dude I can
just jump into that so good
um next did you play
I play see that was my SNES years now I
kind of cheated a little bit because you
know you talked about link to the past
and like
um let's see what else um Mega Man X all
one two three Super Metroid I got a
chance to play all those games because
when I got to college I know I'm jumping
ahead a little bit I played a little bit
of SNES but because we had
um the Sega and then we had the N64 I
did kind of skip the SNES years but but
when I got into college I figured out
how to do an emulator and I had every
SNES game so I went through like the
entire catalog so I went to Metroid
everything yeah
what a game what a spec like in so I did
that for the second yeah I originally
looked for it the Cognito because I
wanted to get all the Sega games I'm
like there's got to be an SNES version
of this right so yeah so if there's any
video game companies that are like you
should be emulating I didn't say nothing
years ago the statute of limitations
like seven years or something yeah but I
did play the Mega Man X Series
um I don't have a favorite there I do
like the first one yeah first ones oh
this is classic
because like honestly like part of Mega
Man is I think one of the reasons why I
like Souls games is because they're in
that punishing like two lives if you
don't get it right you got to go through
you got to learn everything kind of
understand and go and go it's like and
some and Miyazaki took like took the
punishment of older games that had to be
shorter and again you can see them now
Souls games people can beat him in what
like 30 minutes if you know it but the
first thing we played it's like 50 hours
so
no that's yeah when you said Mega Man I
was like man after my own heart it's
amazing classic Man Mega Man soccer oh
did oh see I who did I ask this about
was it uh who did we have on recently
who liked soccer Fifa uh bearded um
Mega Man soccer a thank you outstanding
or new rad no outstanding I can't read
chat did you play Mega Man soccer
played it once okay at least you know it
exists it was fine
I kind of kind of got the Mega Man train
when what was it Mega Man 64. I wanted
that game to be so good yeah and it's so
nice that's not so not that's not the
one you use to sell people in Mega Man
yeah I remember that
see I came into this series a little
later and then I went back and saw the
classics after but that's why I didn't
have the Affinity but when you play the
original you see like okay I get it I
get why at this time friend
Not only was this revolutionary from the
difficulty standpoint and things of that
nature you know it definitely changed
the game I just like the cool I always
thought that artwork was cool all the
designs you know this man that man
everybody had to you know yeah
it was cool man you gotta love it yeah
it's funny because they got away from
that in Mega Man X because everyone gave
him a hard time about it's like we're
done we can't come up with any other
name she can't be like Birdman
like bubble man like like originally
everyone was like bubble man it's a
stupid name but the music from that
level is awesome yup fire awesome that
music is dope although again Mega Man 2
it's it's there I like Mega Man 4 as
well Mega Man 5 I think is where I
started to kind of be like okay I've got
my film Mega Man so I'm gonna do
something different you don't need to
play them all no nice series well so you
definitely got some historic gaming
sounds like we all grew up through much
of the same stuff uh college and
everything like that and then
got into some more Shooters more it
seems like so how did you get from
obviously stuff like Mega Man Star Fox
64 Link to the Past like what got you
into Shooters and what specific ones
kind of LED you in the path towards
obviously what we're talking about today
I get to blame my brother on this one he
could blame me earlier I could explain
my brother on this one so I remember it
was like
2004 or five whenever Cod Modern Warfare
came out he had bought an Xbox
360. and he brought it home and he was
just playing it over the break and so I
was like this is actually he's like dude
you gotta play this dude you got to play
this and so I got into it I'm like oh
man I'm really terrible at Shooters but
we you know we all played GoldenEye back
in the day right we all played GoldenEye
back in the day classic classic
um let's see but um
I got into that and I really started
vibing on the original Call of Duty
Modern Warfare like I just oh that was
my job that's the original um respawn
that's Vincent impelling them boys yeah
that yeah I changed the game that
changed yeah hey Halo was a little bit
in trouble when that came back
I'm gonna be honest with you especially
this is weird coming from like a destiny
side of you I did not play a lot of Halo
when I was in college or even earlier
maybe I played I played like this much
but not a ton like I was mostly a Cod
guy
um and I did a little bit of Halo it's
kind of like a back side of things and I
like the story and I like the music but
it wasn't like a game that I played like
like I would Cod so God was amazing man
fast pace was the the the 60 frames was
was transformative at that time that's
what I realized like this game is
different why is it different it's
moving so much for the reaction is so
much and then you got the perks and you
know kill confirmed and all this it was
just so much going on and I was just
like yo this it was one of those moments
in gaming like okay this is yeah
changing the game for sure yeah
go ahead no no I'll finish I was gonna
say so continue from as you were saying
with Modern Warfare for for me like cod
was transformative because I was
terrible and that's kind of how I like
how I like work with things like I
usually the first time I do it I am
absolutely terrible and no matter what
like I'm just awful and I was the same
way with Destiny too and then like I
eventually just get addicted to it and
just keep doing it until like I'm at
least somewhat good or somewhat average
do you play any Souls games because that
literally sounds exactly how that goes
no and I mean like I tried to do it once
um I'm gonna do because I've got a PS5 I
want to do what's the samurai hero or
Neo Sakura I want to get into that now
PS5 second rows a slightly different
animal somebody in my chat was actually
asking me recently like never played a
Souls game which one would I recommend
and in all honestly I wish they would
refresh bloodborne and kind of get on
that yeah because that is my first one
I've been hooked since bloodborne I
played Dark Souls 3 Jedi fall in order
second row Demon Souls like Demon Souls
is good to see later
but that is not where I would actually
probably tell anyone to start sure
because the quality of life stuff people
learned secure is a different game
because it has something else to it
which I don't want to ruin until you get
there Sakura is awesome though so when
you get there it's so much fun and it is
a little weird because I did have
experience with first person shooters
before like after GoldenEye and before
uh I didn't even ever think of it but
um I when I was younger right before I
went to college
um what was it called
um it was Jedi Outcast came out like
like one of the old pot and that's where
I actually like I didn't even realize it
like I actually had some keyboard mouse
skill because that was a shooter he also
had a lightsaber and then you did look
at the force push stuff and we're
talking like old school and the graphics
were like you know barely there right
there like 133 Hertz Mega computer yup
that's exactly right
so I had done that and so I did have a
little bit of a background there before
jumping onto the Modern Warfare train
and stuff like that but like that game
incognito's right it was so
transformative it completely changed
everything I think Halo and Modern
Warfare those two games are like the
things that pushed that whole idea
forward you know push that whole I mean
we're still going kind of going through
that today yeah absolutely I completely
agree I think it's one of those things
you know for Halo was just it was more
of a
can the console space do first person
and can it do it well and I think that
was the first time and it was just like
wow this feels good this looks good and
I can't believe I'm playing on the
console and then the whole thing with
Lan parties to the evolution of life oh
man online and stuff like that so you
know it was that's where Halo holds for
me for but with you you know I I
remember I remember when Modern Warfare
came out and it's one of those shifts
you you never forget like wow and the
addiction I was like I was horrible I
was horrible I would always get the perk
that when you get killed that you
already on the ground and then you just
shoot for the ground because I was
looking kills I was like let me get the
one that lets you it's called Last Dance
that was the perk I was good at I'd get
my cheap little kills but you try to
come and execute me afterwards I was
already down but um yeah man like it it
was just so good and whatever it was
just willing to keep playing and it
would go on along night and that they
think they did well which Destiny needs
to learn sometimes yeah you know
Parks is the prestige those cool emblems
you get for the amount of time you play
and what you don't want a little Pip
I want those elaborate Platinum glowing
things going on yeah like level 10 your
your emblem looks pretty ridiculous
which is the point you've done a lot
exactly I gotta make like a quick U-turn
back real fast because I keep thinking
of things that I know you told me
um Blockbuster championships and also
Tetris which what was the championship
in first okay hold on let's go grab it
give me a second this is even better
get the exclusive let's go Blockbusters
Championship yo destinations
um when I was younger this was like what
was it like Middle School yeah so
Blockbuster when it was still a thing
they did video game championships and so
like who's the um like it's just funny
because like people are like yeah I'm
the something like I actually have a
legit like it's right here
but my brother really wanted to do it
and it was in 1995 and
um we never went to block we never went
to Blockbuster it I I used to live up in
North Dakota so we had like uh another
rental store that was a really nice like
Mom and Pop Mama yeah
um but then we heard that they were like
offering prizes to do this stuff and so
my brother were like we're pretty good
at video games and my brother like be
one I would I'm just gonna be honest
with you like I was pretty young at the
time and like my brother was just
getting into high school and so they had
two different age brackets so my brother
and I would actually play and we
actually figured stuff out
um but I knew all the tips and tricks
that he did and so he went into like the
high school like older person category
um and he got like fifth no he got a
fourth and so he got like a jacket but I
ended up winning my division which was
basically like middle school so I am the
1995 Store Champion
it's funny because like
um what games by the way sorry so the
two games we had to play was NBA Jam 95
um
that's right
um and then um then uh Judge Dredd of
all things and the key the secret the
secret is there was something in Judge
Dread there was like a little area you
had to go to and you could not win if
you didn't know this area it was a
little secret area where there was the
little there was a little like pick up
it was like worth a million points and
so if you did that you were good the
main reason my brother and I wanted to
do it is because if you won you got free
games you got two free rentals a month
per year oh so like and they let you
have it for like two weeks not like two
days or whatever the old Blockbuster
like they they was like yo we got you yo
so
is actually like the two times and I'm
like dude where's your where is it
back let's go let's see here it's
amazing I didn't even know about this
that is pretty amazing I don't even know
how evolved Blockbuster was in on a
competition level yeah and by the way I
just want to give some love to uh you
know Cognito that's the correct format
right there Genesis
that right there is is historic the
thing that's so cool about it is that
again it's a it's from a culture that so
many this age group this generation have
no idea what we're talking about you
know the days of rental the renting game
and like what you're talking about is
premium premium prize like at that time
what do you get like a day or two for a
rental you know you gotta give it back
to the store that kind of thing they're
giving you two games per month for like
at two weeks at a time kind of deal
that's unheard of and it's just I mean
back at that time renting games renting
systems just before the digital era
everything's all physical and wow you're
taking me back man and I also remember
I'm glad you said that even though you
weren't a member you got you had your
local mom and pop kind of rental place
all family videos or whatever it was
yeah exactly they used to put that their
name on the top of the box cover you
know what I'm saying like it was just uh
classic stuff so like the moment I gotta
speak to this the mom and pop place was
this place called CCI video of all the
names that's like the worst name yeah
um my my we were on an Air Force Base
um up in North Dakota and so this was
like this little tiny town like off the
way but this video store I'm talking
like it was better than like Blockbuster
they had all the games they had all the
videos because all the folks from the
air base would come over they didn't
want to drive like 20 miles to the to
the bigger city they wanted to just go
like five minutes outside of the Town
pick up something and go back to the
base so it was oh that that is actually
kind of transformative you're right
Cognito on that one 100 so yeah you took
me back man that's that's classic
absolutely
yeah you know you're old when you know
Blockbuster like rental time periods and
remember the rewind Machines of VHS and
all that fun so yeah we're all too old
but that takes us through your gaming
years until you plop down in front of
this thing called a beta for the Sci-Fi
world of this game
let's get to it man how did the love
start how did the addiction start okay
so I was really into Titanfall at the
time like that was I didn't move because
I got really sick of cod because this
was like maybe like cod three was around
so I was kind of like it's fine it's
just more Cod you know you can't go back
you can't go back to the original Call
of Duty Modern Warfare so everything was
you know better in a way but it was
always different the Black Ops came and
then but it started to get redundant
right you started to see
so for I literally walked by and this is
gonna sound crazy I literally walked by
in Best Buy I walked by this big upright
thing for Destiny and I literally like
looked at it and I said this is gonna
there's something about this that is
going to change your life somehow I
don't know how like I literally had that
much like you need to get this game I
didn't think too much of it my brother
and a couple other people were like yo
we're into this game like that Destiny
and I was like oh okay I'll buy it okay
whatever you know I didn't think
anything of it I literally just I'll
just buy it everyone's gonna play it so
let's just get it I was still really
into Titanfall like be a legit type
legs
story all multiplayer almost not playing
but look it was still transformative
watch your mouth watch your mouth hey
come on I literally just said all
multiplayer you you took a shot you took
a shot sir you literally know that story
it was trash it was like the voiceovers
while you played volunteers there was no
story but we're not gonna talk but
Titanfall was excellent like everybody's
like I want to be these I want to call
my maximum it's like Titanfall was
awesome and Tuesday now if no by the way
if you haven't played Titanfall 2's
campaign anybody listen to this it's
like six hours and it's amazing yeah
absolutely continue secretary so uh the
thing about uh Titanfall was the wall
running like that for me I'm very much
like a movement I think that's one of
the reasons why I may not like a a Souls
game is because I'm more about like Fast
movements
yeah yeah and so for me like being able
to do those fast movements like kind of
things like really really resonated with
me so when I got into Destiny
um I was playing with my brother and I
and like I didn't think too much of it I
was also like I was a high school band
director and I still am but I was at a
gig where I was very very very very very
busy like unbelievably busy like
marching band season like I had
basically six days a week 10 12 hours 12
10 12 hour days during the fall and
um I didn't really have time to play a
new game I was just kind of chilling and
so then the marching band season kind of
ended and I started getting into some
other games this is like november-ish
um and then a bunch of us were like
yo there's this new raid there's this
vaulted glass we're gonna try and get in
tonight and I'm like level 25 like I
can't even open the door it took us like
two hours to just open the door and I'm
just there getting murdered by the facts
and just like oh my gosh don't let them
overtake the plane
so for me I didn't think much of that
until I started getting up to the level
of doing it and then I played The Raid
and that was the moment I fell in love
with Destiny because it wasn't the Vault
of Glass so much it was just that idea
of this raid and I had never done
anything I didn't like it before great
[__] brother preach it preach it preach
it pre that's what I keep telling people
all the time and a lot of people you
know I know we're gonna get into a whole
raid discussion soon but a lot of people
don't understand how transformative
forgetful just a rain in itself in a
console space I know he's gonna say yeah
but wow did this and wow this thing wow
I get it people haven't experienced that
on a console yeah on a console from a
shooter space and a Cooperative element
so it's six you know and and the thing
that's so unique about it like I said
the game is not really holding your hand
you're you're having to figure things
out as a team yeah man I know you're
about to jump in no oh it's all good
like that's a hundred percent I don't
necessarily think it's the console
versus the PC space I think it was the
fact that it was the first time and I
don't know another game that does this
right now it's a first person version of
it
like the first person person immersion
of it like just being like caught within
it and you feel like you're there yes
just being like Oh my gosh like I'm here
and like all this stuff is happening and
like having to work with your team like
I had never done anything like that
before say I remember just just for fun
memory like it was a stupid part of the
raid but I thought what was so cool when
I started to fall in love with Vlog was
when you had to shoot the oracles right
yeah and everybody's like oh shh
listening to Chimes and paying attention
to stuff like that and again the the
puzzle that you had platforming and
that's the case I was gonna say is too
like you see you see them take first
person and put platforming in there for
like that's probably not that's
something that's not done that often
even do maternal like the second game
they threw more platforming in the
second time around but Destiny literally
like ever raid secret quest dungeon they
all have some version of like I can't
quite see my feet and I have to trust
the jump and somehow they made that feel
good right that's an impressive piece to
take like all these a lot of the game
developers at Bungie are probably like
slightly older than us uh and they're
all gonna be in that age they grew up on
Platformers too like they grew up on the
Marios that you know everybody played
and they're like how do we get this in
there whether it's the jumping puzzle
we'll get to in a little bit whether
it's like the first time you like how
long you're sitting at the bottom of the
Vault of Glass waiting for people to
jump down on those blocks that appear
and disappear and be like and there he
goes again just Falls oh so good can we
just say like can we all just like we
were talking about Mega Man earlier
there's the part before you go into the
Vault of Glass exactly it's Mega Man
it's literally Mega Man you got the
teleporting blocks and stuff like that
and you got to jumper all around it's
literally Mega Man like there is no
other game that like really kind of did
that that it was like super duper
popular so absolutely right there yeah
man yeah yeah you nailed it I mean like
I said he'd throw in great shooting
mechanics on top of that and then pause
fights and stuff like that and then you
just got this magical thing so like yeah
it's similar very similar history is
being you because that's I was I was
just like like you were 20 25 didn't you
know what else I I played it like a a
traditional campaign game thinking it's
it's finite and this is the end and
that's it so continue
before I did that I we we got into the
destiny 1 beta um just because my
brother and I were into it and I kind of
started to Vibe on it a little bit
because I'm like this is pretty cool and
like I when they opened up the moon I
still remember the day it was a Saturday
there was a Saturday where the old hours
and it was still during the summer so
like I still wasn't 100 vibing on the
game but Titanfall was getting old and I
wanted to do something so when I started
exploring the moon underneath in like
the shrine Of Orcs And all this I'm like
oh my God there's all this stuff like
this is really cool and like I really
got into that
um and then I got to the point where I
was like the least invested Destiny
player and then I became the most like
to the point where all of my friends and
stuff like that were like nah guess this
rate ain't gonna happen sorry and I was
like guys we can finish this well I
gotta go to bed I'm like dude I'm
finishing this so that's when I started
and I feel bad about this and I I still
gotta give like my brother and on one of
my really good friends Admiral
um he they gave me a really hard time
and rightfully so but I wanted we had
the we had the Atheon checkpoint and all
we needed to do was finish it and there
they all went to bed because they're
like that's Friday night I just want to
go to bed and I'm like no I'm getting
this done and whether I said so at that
point
that's when lfg G's had started yeah so
I that was my first experience with lfg
is like I know the raid I know what to
do I just need to finish it and on my on
my first clear no it's first or second
second clear I got Vex Mythic last oh
and then like that was it was after
after they patched it so it wasn't like
a Godly weapon but it was still good and
one day I just like literally I'm just
jamming with my brother and Admiral the
the people that I usually played with
and I literally just pulled it out
and then um daily was like is it is that
Vex I'm like
so but from that moment I was hooked I
wanted to see what the new raids were I
liked the strikes I thought that they
were interesting I was still just trying
to get into the gun play because I I had
forgotten how to do like first person
shooting because I like I got away from
the golden eyes and like the cods and
stuff like that I still did the
TitanFall stuff but it was a completely
different feeling
um with how it plays because it wasn't
Halo what all the other games were not
Halo inspired so now I was getting into
like a Halo inspired game so
yeah all right so raids are your big
things we'll get to your mission stuff a
little later with all your big record
but
you and I match on like top raid top
expansion 100 yep so thinking explain
just like for you like I'm not gonna
argue and usually we go through this
with a lot of people it's like what are
your top few raids so I know you're
number one but like just kind of go top
three or four raids for all of the
franchise so far where do you put things
at this point you've had some time with
even the recent ones so if it's in the
mix you've got time now
gotta be gotta be King's fall King's
fall is the best raid in Destiny history
period there is no argument
I'll even tell people doing this I do
like I do like my Vault of Glass I do
like ball to Glass and I loved it that
was the one I fell in love with but
King's fall was the first time and I
still argue that this is something that
Destiny and Bungie needs to get behind
they need to get this because this is
what made it great
the campaign the quests the end game yes
he raid everything was tied together it
was the big taken war and when you did
that it was from a story standpoint from
a lore standpoint from a gaming
standpoint from a quest standpoint like
it was perfect oh absolutely perfect and
like absolutely when you killed oryx
when that got done you just felt like a
boss it was amazing it is the best raid
I know that but but
you you explained it perfectly and I
respect you so much because you are
making an amazing case so I'll go I and
I feel like that's gonna come back in
harmony
after that last wish is the second pass
now the only reason I would say Last
Wish would be second it is because it
has all of those elements yes but the
problem is that the story
this like it wasn't the Forefront like
the story that connects the two things
in like the the the choice whatever and
stuff like that like they're they're
connected but you don't know that they
are unless if you're unless if you're
reading all the lore and you understand
what's going on with sabathune and
everything else like that I think two if
Riven was not
cheesable
so when you know they're very legit oh
no I've done Riven legit a lot of times
but I'm saying like the thing that made
oryx Stand Out is that there were no
shortcuts unless you're esoteric if
you're esoteric but I mean we know him
yeah but he's a but he's a robot it
doesn't matter He's Just Not a Human
Being
um but uh you know
solo all that stuff because I mean he
just spends all the time to do it but if
you're an above average group and you
you want to talk about those two things
having that shortcut cheapens that
experience
of last week is it the fault of last
words
is gonna be
versus three because but it's it's like
those three are just the upper echelon I
am not and I'm gonna say this and it's
probably gonna make like some not
friends
I I did
um Wrath of the machine on day one it
was fun
it was fine it was a good raid it was
fine it was serviceable and some people
are like oh my God it was the best rate
and I'm like it was to me it felt too
short I feel like yeah
I got you good too and that's and that's
my argument with deep Stone [__] now so
deep Stone Crypt would probably be
because I think it's a fun raid but it's
too short I always talk man I talk about
a stream when I'm doing it after that is
um after you're done with the second
encounter where you go versus aatrax you
should go into space and instead of
going back into the ship there are those
Fallen ships off to the side right you
should go chase tannix off of his ship
blop his [__] his ship so that the only
way that he can escape like it even
works from a story standpoint right so
you blow up his ship like you go over to
his catch do all the stuff you have like
maybe another encounter into over there
blow it up he has no choice but to go
over to the Deep Stone crypto he's like
I won't kill these guys so so then it
makes sense it's like why are you just
gonna
slam like this into Europa because
there's another cat his catch is right
over there it just it doesn't work so
for me like there's a lot of missed
Opera not a lot but a little bit of a
missed opportunity there and they could
have made that raid even stand out even
more so okay so you're just to clarifies
what you're able to get all your points
in order he's like I would like this uh
can the court reporter read back please
[Music]
so the issue with deep Stone [__] for
Mano is
purely length right so so your thing is
if there was maybe one other encounter
or something else cooler that was added
then it would Elevate that plus it's not
really connected to the story other than
yes hey here's a line at the beginning
that says this raid is connected to the
campaign
the thing and that's the reason why it's
lower than taking king
king's fall is because you know you're
fighting oryx like if Aramis was in
there and somehow like Aramis like
somehow activated tanics or did
something like like my beef is like
where did tannix come from
well that's I don't have no house but
like yeah I was disgusting why did he
get recruited for this job yeah for this
job like I didn't want to see him I
didn't want to see him necessarily I'm
with you there all your reasoning there
me in your pocket so I guess that I want
to flip back because I love your three
right your three is amazing four I'm not
gonna dispute the things you said like
you you are in Pocket it is I call it
it's a rage right like it's a man's rate
yeah yeah that's you you raided that
night right you did it you did the
sisters you did golgaroth you know what
I'm saying well priest you you were you
fought this mythical being the campaign
transition perfectly into the um actual
raid and that's one thing Bungie doesn't
do enough of right right immediate evil
we were at um the little uh was it the
bungee thing at the guardian gcx yeah
you know we spoke to some people from
the ray team I I had to stress that like
that is
Last Wish I'ma with you there now the
thing about I think you're being hard on
Reverend I can be very hard
I think it'd be very difficult that
first of all it was a mythical we didn't
even know we knew of amankara because of
D1 items and Exotics where we had to
read Lord we like okay what is that and
they don't exist so it's kind of a
mythical thing to fight the first uh who
in its own right living in their own
right was just as amazing if you caught
it legitimately right
exactly from a scale standpoint
it's not oryx oryx is oryx I'm never
gonna say that but it's not as far as
some people will see like this River was
a thing you know what I'm saying so
that's that and then you had the Cur the
the after effect like even better yeah
you know you didn't have to shattered
Throne you have the whole you know the
cities in the recursion like this is
this is the next level kind of stuff so
um what you did you got vlogged there
I'm there not a question I got for you
it's just so disrespectful to wrestling
yeah I was like oh no yeah what is
number four I have to know this okay so
the reason why well and I put deep Stone
[__] at number four
um I really like I really like that but
um for me wrath for me the deciding
point because you mentioned it Cognito
you mentioned it because you talked to
the rate team is like this like they
deviate from the story right the first
time it happened was
um was rather than machine was the first
time it's like yeah we're fighting the
iron Lords and stuff like that and then
all of a sudden like oh here by the way
there's this Fallen guy that went and
got the Siva
wait did wait where did you come from
well you just snuck in there and he's
got the Siva now
go fight him like to me I'm like nope
I'm out thanks for playing like it's a
fun raid I I Love Actually I actually
don't really like the boss fight as much
I like the what's the guy that's it's
been so long since I've done it
sick fight you throw the ball I like
that
you got the TVs in the back yeah
yeah you gotta you got a high you gotta
slide in the room and then the thing oh
I love that yeah I'm just gonna plant
this seed and uh cognitos argument a lot
of the time when it comes to raids is
based on many factors you've said a lot
story
bosses like gameplay
connection big one Loot and this is
where cognito's argument of Wrath the
machine comes into play so I'm planting
that
let it marinate for a second
thoughts yeah I'm just curious what his
four is that's all I wanted because he
said he said before
yeah deep Stone Crypt is poor yeah I
don't know after that I'd have to give
some serious thought to the lat the next
couple
I have some Affinity with crota because
that's where that that's more that's
less of an objective love versus a
subjective like that's where my channel
started like the first video I ever did
was a weapon review in the style of like
and this was one of the things I wrote
in the notes was do you remember when my
name is bife did weapon reviews no no it
wasn't huge then that's before he was
lore Daddy yeah he was like essentially
like Halo and he was doing stuff and so
I made mine there so crowd is not fair
crota back in its day was an under
leveled sir I still liked Raph
um and let me let me answer something
for you Cognito too I'm gonna say this
I'm again I'm a musician so the destiny
one music
um Marty McDonald whatever happened with
him in Reddit I'm not going into it
not not touching that that's completely
like disparate from this entire entire
conversation but
um the music from D1 was
10 times the music we have in D2 with
the exception of of a couple of songs
from D2
um man ironically they keep using Marty
O'Donald
the ending thing once you're done with
the campaign you know the first time we
see the black Fleet after the campaign
where the traveler explodes that whole
thing is from
um the The Music of the Spheres that
Marty O'Donnell made that's like the
Fourth Movement of that yeah and so
that's Marty O'Donnell stuff the theme
that was the black Fleet uh but anyways
the the three songs number one song
completely underrated because everyone
skips it because of the ribbon fight the
Riven music slaps
and it's the second phase that does it
the phase that everyone skips because
they just blast through it it's the
ending part this it's like this heroic
horn Rock thing very halo-esque but no
one hears it because everyone just skips
it bro
the Queen's wall
is something special yeah yeah that's
great too I got I got a ride for my guys
now listen Marty arguably to go I'm
never gonna disrespect one all right
Marty used to go we know what Destiny
one music is even now replaying some of
these strikes it hit me I'm like damn
you know what I'm saying suffix oh there
it is oh man like body you know there's
certain stuff that it just can't be
touched I'm not gonna say but I will say
this I gotta ride now but I gotta shout
out my guys Sky Lewin Mike Salvatore
because it to me
when it comes to P I know the expansion
was bad
but curse of Osiris has some amazing
music bro the Egyptian the Egyptian
theme was crazy
um as far as like the tracks as far as
going forward um well I I'm not gonna
say that they're they're oh my God like
this is better than whatever whatever
but it's a different vibe yeah and some
of the things that they have done
are really standing like like we can't
like we cannot not talk about deep Stone
[__] oh and then
like if the spacewalk almost don't make
you teary-eyed just like yo what is
going on yeah this is the most beautiful
thing I have ever heard it's in the
perfect spot it's a perfect respite
between two crazy encounters you just
did and then the sound with space and
all like bro that thing right there
amazing it's special yeah like very
special gotta shout those guys out those
that was the other that was the other
the one of the other three songs like
for me it's the Riven fight deep Stone
lullaby and then the final red War
Mission what is that it's not is it
journey I think is what it's called I'd
have to look up the name
the one at the final yeah the whole
callous like where it's like they get
the Kronos quartet to play the uh to
play the then they start like
it starts very slowly and then it slowly
builds
um
let's see there was one other moment in
Destiny 2 where the music was amazing
it's in the it's in the mission when
you're up in the almighty and you know
the the moment I got goosebumps in D2 in
The Campaign which the campaign of D2
was arguably better than the D1 campaign
all right the moment when you're in the
almighty and you go in the pipes and
then the music just starts going and
then you look over and the Sun is like
10 feet from you and that music started
there there there's like four moments
there like and I shouldn't say that the
music's not as good but there's like I
think a lot of that was you know
um salvatory I think you know because
Salvatore and Mario Donna work that was
the yeah they worked together on the D1
stuff so I feel like a lot of the great
stuff comes from there
um and obviously we that it's been like
seven years since the whole thing
happened with Marty O'Donnell but yeah
um the the I think that's the other
reason why I put deep Stone Crypt up
higher is that Space Walk The Deep Stone
lullaby
I go fight you yeah
[Laughter]
I was like just those moments it's like
it's so funny that you guys say deep
Stone a little bit because for sure one
of the ones that I never expected was
the second mission in Destiny 2's
campaign of red War when your powers are
stripped oh that shot that song
yeah it was just something I never
expected the same with like deep Stone
lullabies special because the tones the
silence the like the space was perfect
but just like you're stripped and they
like they encapsulated that like
desperate I just had my yeah the just
the emotion of like I just had my power
Stripped Away you feel like you're
literally dragging one limb at a time
across like the ground just to try and
not get killed by the cabal stuff
driving by on the streets above that was
a cool one too but yes like I mean and
now as you guys said like sepix comes
back and they put the rock remix in
which I'm so happy about oh that one
I'll play it out I'm like he's gotta be
losing it right yeah I just I was like I
was like I wonder what I played it on
stream like the first time too and I was
like wonder what mission they're gonna
or what music they're gonna have is like
the Rock and I just like literally
started going I can't head back like you
can but I was like oh it's still gonna
make you more heroic than you are like
don't you feel like at that point don't
you play better because the music goes
on like it is
every time
so so much so that I mean I think after
that because we were on originally like
a raid discussion with music yeah I'd
have to give it some deep thought
because I actually I'm one of the
weirdos that actually likes
um I really liked the pace and the speed
of oh my gosh why am I forgetting the
third the third Leviathan raid why am I
forgetting that right now
um
Spire I love I actually really loved
Spire of stars but that raid gets such a
bad rap because you know you mentioned
it before the loot what are you gonna
get a fusion rifle yeah
like you're gonna get armor that looks
like arguably it's just a re-skin of
everything else yeah yeah
um I liked Leviathan and I do have a
I've got the day one of Leviathan like a
bunch of us like did that but like
I don't know like it just doesn't hit me
the same way
um Scourge is fun but it's Scourge
remind is kind of like
um to me like the Wrath of the machine
rate I mean I mean it's funny because
it's the fallen and it's the same kind
of thing like they're both great but
they're not like my favorite favorite if
that if that makes sense
I'm in this weird space Willow why do we
go along with the race stuff but I have
to finish this up like I'm in this weird
space with Leviathan like
I know it's not beloved by a lot but I
do I think it holds a special thing for
me two reasons one
I was one of the guys that was like yo
cabal needs their shine like they need a
raid and I like the whole Ambiance of it
like I'm like the whole everything is
over the top luxurious the gold is just
like oh it's complete like even when he
says get grow fat from Strike like
everything about callus is over the top
so the music is great too the music was
great in that original Marine music was
good
um I think for me why I I I think lavada
has to get a little bit more credit is
let's be real Not only was all right
people can say okay it's not it's it's
more like a American Ninja Warrior do
these tricks do this go through the
gauntlet you know do I get it the badge
all I I get it but when you actually
look at the infrastructure of that raid
as far as the ship when you when you
when you skip figs right and you go
through the underbelly and you see how
massive and all this stuff is connected
it's pretty impressive and I I do like
the last fight I do I mean the boss
fights you like the boss fight I thought
that was cool I thought it was a nice
little spoiler at the end a little
tricky twist yeah get a little twist you
know what I'm saying I like that look
you know I get it it's not it's I don't
know if it's like my top five but I I
don't think it I think it gets a lot of
bet it gets a bad rap sometimes but it's
not as bad as people I think you know
don't give a credit for but what do you
guys do I completely agree like to me
like Leviathan was a Great Raid It
suffers from the same problem that wrath
the machine did and I mean if you think
about it as the first D2 rated it's the
same problem of you know
here's the storyline here's Gaul instead
of fighting yeah you're right hey by the
way there's this random guy this giant
guy yeah yeah
the only way you know he exists is one
adventure and then we're gonna go do a
whole raid about him and you're like
yeah you're right and that's the thing
too is like the connection between the
stories when things have gone so well
and when it disconnects you're like just
take something away from it and when
it's done so well and even like I oddly
let crota's end higher than most people
ever seem to just because like I always
thought thematically it fit the hive so
well oh yeah story connection it's
honestly been so long I forget kind of
how we led into that with besides just
like heiress is here we did a few things
and now we're going into the hive but
just when they hit as you said kind of
like here's like Gaul Dominus shiny hot
shiny cabal you're like it's there's a
big switch to it so it's it's always
weird to see that but the the sword Bear
music when you pick that music up and
you had the sword you're like oh my God
I'm gonna take care of some stuff okay
yeah mm-hmm that was corota has a
special spot for me it was one of my but
like one of my best friends and it was
we two I know people sold the thing but
we just we too man Flawless the rain and
that was just like one of those moments
and we didn't like worked on the
encounters for a couple hours did it
knocked it out and we were like that was
fantastic and it's just like it always
felt just like it fit the hybrid and
that's why you say it's like the Fallen
raids have this like
feel to him where it's like you got
Wrath of machine with Siva you got
scourge of the past they've been a
little shorter they have some good they
have some bad but it's just like they
Destiny overall has done like cabal
giant opulence like Vex you got time and
now we had it's I'm always I'm curious
to see if they ever bring in said
question mark fifth race ever anything
how they make that different should be
very I have some I have some theories on
that which I don't know if the audience
will like but whatever happens and stuff
all that crazy I think there's gonna be
a destiny three
whether it's Destiny 3 or something else
we keep wondering what size of team and
we'll get to this in a little bit but
like is working on Destiny 2 because
what is the rest of the studio doing
because sometimes you wonder how much is
going on so we'll put a pin in that and
come back to it but hey we've talked
about just history for like an hour I
don't know it's just some other stuff
going on no honestly I love it when we
get off on tangents like this because
time flies and I'm like I probably need
to be the whole producer thing and get
things going here so we got season of
The Chosen we got a whole new season and
how have you guys been it's been
approximately like you know 72 hours
three or four days since we got it maybe
96 but how have you guys been this week
how much have you played what have you
jumped into Top Line a little drill down
on a bunch of stuff but just thoughts on
the season so far season of The Hunt set
a very low bar so if you guys say it's
better than that I get it but where do
you guys feel let's go Mana where you at
that good huh oh wow
there it goes excuse me I'm Darth Vader
sorry the problem with drip feed content
is that you you can't really
have a rating of the Season until you
look back on it yeah absolutely right
you're absolutely right season of The
Hunt I think I like the idea of the
harbinger Mission I wish the mission
would have been secret but I know what
they were trying to do because they're
like we need to give a whisper or an
outbreak style Mission we need to give
it more replayability and that's good I
liked it I for me especially for my
background you guys know about my The
Whisper the Zero Hour of stuff and we
can talk about that whenever
um for me the uh it kind of took away
from it a little bit but then when I
started playing it's like it's still a
really cool like cool fight and stuff
like that for me season and chosen
I don't know if we've seen the best
stuff from it yet you know it's only
been three days it's fun chasing after
new weapons and I will say this is the
first time that like there are weapons
that I'm actively like engaging with and
like I want to farm this I want to go
after this
um
I'm not
really 100 sold on the Battlegrounds
campaign I I one thing I wish they would
they would do is they they always have a
harder version of whatever the activity
is later on throughout the season I wish
it would evolve like so it's like here's
the opening of it you throw the balls at
the batteries or whatever and then you
go chase and then the ship and then you
kill the guy like it would be cool if
like to lead into the raid maybe the
next time we do it and I don't think
they're gonna do this but it would be
cool if they did is like then you go
into the land tank and you kind of
experience what's there and it's kind of
like a little bit of a mini raid but you
don't know that stuff because it's the
first three days I think that
for me
um there needs to be something else
tied to it and again it's hard because
you know you do a raid I hope that
there's a dungeon at the end of the
season which I feel like they kind of
teased yeah we can we can cover that
spoiler thought dot pick discussion
press kid situation later but we'll get
there I'm I'm medium on it like it's
it's not so much different but I think
that it's hard because unless if you
have something that just slaps and is
amazing it's hard to come back from
season the hunt and that's that's the
thing you kind of led into that is it's
like you know if you say it's better
than seasonal hunts you're right it sets
a really low bar the problem is that
that's what the community expects it's
just gonna be like another season the
chosen or it's going to be like a season
or excuse me season of the uh hunt plus
one and so people don't feel that
connection to come back they're like
bored of the loop already so
and we're still in the honeymoon period
of it
so I think it's medium it's it's good
it's fun to jump in and Hunt guns but my
final answer is like more Destiny is not
the answer because
it sounds like a uh a video I've watched
oh yeah by a person that also starts
with a d yeah
um
that's a legit and I think like all of
us started in the beta I started the
alpha like wherever you started from
you've been playing for a while and we
are now getting to the point of
franchise fatigue yes and like we're in
year seven it's like cool we're in year
seven it's like for Destiny it's like
and this is the point for me and I said
it last season all the time I'm
literally looking to witch Queen because
that's where maybe an armor 3.0 is
because Joe literally said it at one
point like we want armor not just be
your annual stat replacement I'm like I
got my season pass armor from hunt yep
it's like 66 66 I was like I master like
that I'm literally good into a witch
Queen and I'm like I don't need to touch
anything until then so that's literally
5 8 of my gear I don't need to worry
about ever I'm going to be able to have
all the functionality once it's
masterworked I'm truly done so then
you're like weapons there are cool
weapons like first off the Exotic bow
which we'll get to in a second just a
lot of fun doesn't have to be amazing
may not be the highest CPS just fun
um and some of the weapons are cool it's
like but that's kind of thing is like
how many and some of the perks honestly
are legit fun to go after as you said
there's the idea that there are some
weapons that I want this role I want to
go for fill in the blank but then when
you get that say you get it now say you
get it in a few weeks maybe you're
chasing it for longer you get a little
frustrated how many Battlegrounds are
you gonna have fun running how many
convoluted I need to get gold to put
into my hammer to put a champion a
challenger Medallion in there to smash a
tribute chest to put a charge into the
hammer to open One Umbrella Ingram five
times and like how
how many times are you gonna want to do
that and then how many times you're
gonna care to and that's where
that's like the you know it's like it is
the honeymoon phase it's fun to jump in
and play and all this stuff feels kind
of new but it's like when you're like oh
I gotta go run five Battlegrounds to get
and I know the hammer is going to get
upgrade and we'll talk about drip feed
time getting piece there too
but again it's it is one of those like
they need as you said more Destiny I
mean this is like that is lying so I'll
say it it's like at this point I don't
need more Destiny I want what do you
want something different like I mean
that's what would be different I'm just
asking what will be different the hard
answer and that's exactly no I know
believe me I fully get it yeah it's like
it is a looter shooter game and that's
why the whole idea of a destiny 3 is
something you and I had talked about
like at this point the things that I
won't change like I want armor stats to
matter I want something different there
I want when you the whole leveling 50
points arbitrarily a season just like I
you start doing that oh I gotta go
strikes I gotta care about Pinnacles but
why do I even give a damn because like
four days ago I was able to run all the
Lost sections I wanted to and now I
can't like just this system we're at now
is
just but that's the thing it's like I
sit there and I was going back and forth
between Uh Kevin it was on Twitter it's
like I have talked to him off and on and
it was just like so the whole leveling
ground what do you want well and I saw a
send a nomad we had him on before he's
like what if it's you know a little bit
every season or maybe every other season
you go up I heard another podcast what
is the magical is it just an expansion
you do your leveling and then every
season pass you get new stuff to do with
new guns to go for but the new people
have the incentive for the grind like I
don't have that answer and that's the
hard part for Bungie and I get that but
for the veterans it's like
if like this witch Queen and lightfall
are going to be kind of similar for a
while till we get like a destiny 3
that's where I wonder how long some of
these people are going to hang on
yeah
and I I want to like I've got some
follow-up but I know Cognito I haven't
heard what you said I have to think
about it what do you think about the
season well I got a lot to say so you're
gonna say so first oh no I mean like
so here's the reason why we needed
Destiny 3 that's the problem okay so
what they tried to do is and this is
this is kind of my beef with Bungie if I
was gonna have a conversation with them
I would say the problem that they have
is that instead of trying to solve a
problem they try and get around the
problem I think the first time we saw it
and then I'll make my case here the the
thing that they have the issue with is
that you know the big problem is is that
only like 10 of the population of the
game have done a raid so I think that
they look at those statistics from a
data standpoint and they say Okay since
this is happening we need to do this and
I think it's completely the backwards
way to do it and I think that plays into
the whole idea of the Raves are not
connected to the storyline I think
that's a solution that they came up with
to quote skit around the problem
um that's just my thought of doing it
and that seems to be the thing that they
do and again I don't have beef with it
it's just that sometimes if you just
solve a problem it will make things a
million times better than getting around
the problem and that's the the first
time that happened was Wrath of the
machine is it's like we need to solve
the we need to get around the problem of
you know not everyone in the game has
done the raids so we want to make sure
that we make sure that you feel
fulfilled when you do the base campaign
and you do all the other stuff so we're
gonna make the rated extra Thing versus
The Raid being the end game the real end
game here right and I think Destiny the
idea of the sun setting and all those
other things is
getting around the production costs of
having a destiny 3 this early
um that's just my take on it the whole
sun setting thing is they're getting
around the problem of people needing a
grind the drip B content is getting
around the problem of production stuff I
think that you know skill up is another
person that I watch a lot and he
actually talked about fantastic video he
um he has an amazing take and I think I
heard it and I was like this is perfect
I don't think we should have the Four
Seasons or the three seasons I think we
should get a Content drop which is a
massive expansion and let it just be
huge six months another thing and then
we get something else and so those two
children on this podcast said that
hopefully
because it doesn't feel like it always
feels good when there's something fresh
and new to do and I know that for my
brother he took essentially a year off
from Destiny and when he came back he
was like dude this is awesome there's
all these other things to do but if
you're constantly getting the game you
get that French
um wow this is uh listen to you guys I
was just going through ahead I got so
much to talk about man it's just crazy
first yeah first thing first you know
season and chosen
um
I didn't know what to expect you know
obviously the last season was not up to
Snuff and you know I I tempered my
expectation coming in because I'm like
look again resources you know like
you're saying Mano going around the
problem you know what are we really
gonna get and then based on what we know
with Bungie with the two season Cadence
you know how much could they really have
changed for this one right you know so I
already came in like keep your
expectations in check right
I gotta be ready with y'all um I thought
this season started out fantastic and
again we're in the honeymoon phase we
are this is we're so early right all I'm
gonna say is the way the reason why I'm
glowing about it is twofold one the
thing about Destiny that really draws me
into a season personally is when the
narrative for the most part is strong or
if it's continued and the thing I like
that again I would die on this hill
whether this me and taxi went out and
the taxi actually agree with me at the
end was one of the missions and I forgot
what season it was where I think a
season of dawn where you got Devil's
ruin right and you get that was ruined
and there's a conversation between
Osiris
um what you call it a saint shax is in
it one of the great the best uh bits of
law you get from those three the thing
that I liked about this immediately you
hit the ground running here's a cinema
here's what's going on with Zavala
here's what's going on kylo's coming
okay cool cool you get the the table the
the the Bentley moment right boom okay
cool then I'm thinking all right they're
done right no okay Guardian we're gonna
go over we got this thing for the Hound
we built this station here Crow is in
right okay cool the thing that I was
cheering for
was Saladin I was like fine yeah we're
using salad with all these people I'm
like yes and then he's in it and then
there was so much lore in these
conversations even when you do the
Battleground yeah as an Osiris Fanboy I
know that him and Silent don't get along
because I remember when sounding you I
think during Christmas time you go to
the Iron Man and you listen to them talk
he's like oh yeah I'm Cyrus that you
know you know he's cursed from the city
so to hear them banter
during that mission is Osama was like
yeah we did Aphrodite leave you I didn't
know Iron orange did such and such it
was just beautiful so I'm sitting there
and I'm like yo this is what I'm talking
now because the thing about Destiny they
try to say is this living evolving world
but they don't use the characters half
the time
the cats are just sitting there and no
one's getting updated dialogue and no
one so I I like to feed like now it
feels like everyone is involved mine is
like that's true
I don't know she lost her voice since
Osiris now got all the shot she's lost
her voice I don't know what's going on
but I will say so just for the law
standpoint I'm cheesing like these kind
of things
narratively keep me it feels like a
cartoon episode okay what's going on now
they gotta keep it up they got okay this
is just to start but I I like that now
as far as the um to ease point you know
with the uh the seasonal ground the
activity right which is Battleground
let's be it's it's fairly simplistic but
I do like the fact that it feels like
it's all out wall and like they do a
couple of things that someone nuanced
things that I like which is
why one thing when you start playing D1
strikes you I start to realize yo D1 had
a lot of width a lot of wide open space
in the strike you know like Arenas
that's right and I feel like D2 is was
more Corridor e it that you know that's
something to get all these open space
like how the cosmodrome you feel like
this big open space it almost feels like
it open that's the tank fight is like
the biggest piece like that right the
thing I liked about Battlegrounds was
they do some nuances where instead of
just a car already go forward this
dude's coming up on the side there's
people there's smaller people behind you
and again it's simplistic go kill shoot
stuff but it felt fun and I just felt
like yo we were getting overwhelmed now
granted you know it's gonna have to be a
a larger difficulty version of this at
some point because we're gonna Blaze
through it but um I thought that was
cool you know what I'm saying and in the
whole you know mechanic of doing the
thing Focus rolling I love all that
stuff
um the weapons we got got to talk about
it oh they're great these weapons are
amazing yeah these weapons are made
we've got they're only new weapons
amazing new perks have y'all gotten that
on one with the rocket that you shoot
hey
I've heard about it I don't have one yet
bro y'all gotta get that me too God
gotta get it is hilarious like that that
rocket launcher what is it um
the new one the new one
let me look at them that rocket is who's
faster at them come on damn load I mean
you're you're having a stream so I might
end up I might end up getting there like
legendary Rockets are a thing right now
like if you got legendary Rocky with a
nice dick I got one with ambitious
assassin field prep impact casing I'm
only sitting there with like nine maybe
and sometimes two going back to back
like that's not bad with the fast reload
too there's another perk on it like the
one that makes the rocket go
ridiculously fast
that's the way I got impulse amplifier
with chain reaction yeah and it got the
the impact cases so not only is it good
at Direct Hit I can add clear right then
you throw in I got it I gotta shout out
tiku right when I first got the ball I'm
like man that's fun but he will laugh at
me I get it right so I'm shooting it
like I'm like I can't even kill ass with
this this is trash like I was I was
using it completely wrong I didn't know
what I was doing so I'm firing it didn't
read the user manual yeah I'm like I'm
like what is this this so my boys like
know that y'all start the primer yeah
and then you gotta hold that also it's
like I'm sitting The Little Match on
them and then because I'm thinking the
match is the is the DPS I'm like this is
garbage these red bars are laughing at
me so did I shoot the thing and I start
to see the madness that I am creating
the explosions that you could create War
myself with this bill oh dude yeah it is
so much fun with this damn I've never
had this much fun with bowls Rockets
SMGs
with Frenzy
have you got frenzy yet just like I
haven't got friends yet so frenzy it's
weird for the activation I was messing
with chat the other day it's like it
takes a little bit for it to kick in
like 10 maybe 15 seconds that's a little
while but then once it's on it's
literally just on look until you're done
with the encounter so it increases
damage handling reload Speeders up some
three things for the whole fight you can
switch off switch back still there wow
I've got it on the uh sniper and it
actually slaps and Crucible it's
actually kind of interesting okay so
that's the thing I got on a sniper got
on a boat and I wanted to test like
range what is the activation time when
you're like halfway on the other side of
the world is it like once you start
firing is that how it takes the combat
you know I gotta talk to my boy Castle
about testing that because he's been
doing that castle is live
um he he's been doing a lot of that like
there's a couple of perks like where
like the Aeon perks if you're across the
map they'll activate and so that might
be something he can test and I can like
add him and just be like yo but that's
the question is like when does this
actually start because there are times
like where I'm getting like 150 hit
marker with a with a sniper if because
I'm deep in the battle and I just turned
to it and then I just hit the body and
they're toast and so you know it's not
as good as a headshot of course but if
you get I've got a quick draw frenzy
roll on the sniper and it slaps and
Crucible if you if you can hit your
shots it's really good but somebody
better than me could have probably used
my slide shot frenzy much better than I
could on that far future sniper rifle
but me yeah yeah but yeah like I said I
mean look it's early it's honeymoon
phase I get it but man I have put in
tons of hours like I am shocked at how
much I'm playing I'm like yo I'm I'm
just a back in the floor I'm addicted to
loot chases there yeah things are going
forward and now it's just a matter of
how they continue the story for it for
me you know how redundant will the next
Battleground but I do I will say this E
I like the Europa what I like the
contrast to the Europa one and the other
one and um you know obviously they're
gonna have these those phase mechanics
and stuff like that where they're not
gonna let us melt this boss all the way
those days were over the days if you
have the chess piece for the Titan
will you tell me about this I like
glasses
like I haven't done the testing but they
are literally insta-killing basically
everything Gambit bosses in yeah like
instant Battlegrounds three guys no it's
just the new exotic take cyber crash
yeah and magnifies it by I don't know
how much but literally they took five
on aatrax took him down to his last
stand last guy killed him
yeah and they all just ran that exotic
and they're getting past
um you know those what are they called
the mechanics of the top the damage
Gates they're getting past that like
they're going because they're going
because they're going so fast about what
they'll do is they'll stack it up I'll
maybe see if I can tweet at you at
Cognito it's like you're glad putting it
up there
um and like because all four of them
have it it's like okay guys three two
one go and because they spend enough
time the air not only do they get an
overshield but they also get like a
little bit more like a ton more damage
it's it's essential like someone said it
on it's Celestial fist talk yeah it is
and some people say it's more damage
than Celestial yeah so it's so powerful
it's breaking the damage gate yeah
that's what you're saying yeah
insta-kill like they'd be like a Gambit
boss like instantly gone I'll I'll tweet
it you give me just a second aatrax was
like they did five they found the other
guy it's like all right let's see and
they had one left done
but let's go get shot finally nerfed oh
dude 100 it sucks though is thunder
crash has been so bad for so long I know
for so long and then they're like oh
here's this exotic and be like oh we
made it too strong and I'm like don't
take it away literally I saw Tassie
tonight was like glad I swear to God if
you get this nerfed and I'm like
that's what sucks about it is yeah
that's gonna be a next week like kind of
Nerf yeah that's a patch no Nerf that is
waiting for that yeah you know Daddy
Bunchy do not like us melting things so
fast you know that you know we don't
like that
yeah
I should be fair Cognito because like I
I think I I need to kind of just follow
up on what I said I don't think that
this season's gonna be bad I just don't
know yet like yeah we know it's early I
I feel like that was the thing about
season the dawn for me at first for me
season that the dawn didn't really
excite me and then I looked back on it
and I'm like damn really really good
I missed a lot of that stuff it was the
best season out of Shadow keep by far
it's been the best at least we as we can
tell like so I I don't want to make it
seem like I'm selling this season short
it's just that I because I think that's
partially because the drip fed content
is like you don't really know until you
get to the day before the next expansion
you look back and you're like you know
what this is a great season and I think
the helm you're right like I love Lord
Saladin as a character and I wish you
would get more like get more like into
the game I think that's one of the other
things that's nice about the helm
instead of having them to have to do the
lines and put it into the tower all of
that narrative stuff can happen in the
helmets and it feels and it feels good
and you know what not to cut you I I
yeah because you're on fire bro it felt
like Avengers to me I felt like I was at
the Avengers table Yeah Zavala popped in
Crows back there it's like it's so cool
and I I think the helm has potential I
was like yo I like this and then the
other thing that they did which I'm a
big fan again how you win Cog over is
lower continuity narrative and voice
acting right guess what I went over to
Osiris said guess who had things to say
I was like oh you talk now okay let's
see what you got to say these going on
I'm like okay cool oh sat there just
listened to Crow you know he's like yeah
our core is not ready that's what
doesn't seem to be elected to come over
I was like oh these are the things that
make it feel like a living game when
they have these again people say oh
that's all right I love this stuff I
think this is what makes it now a a
Saturday morning cartoon this is you
tune in tune in next week when what such
and such is gonna happen like if they
have the potential the key is will they
continue to do it you know I'm saying if
they have the potential to do it and I I
think the helm sets it up perfect now I
gotta agree with e or one thing though
on the um my only nitpick that I don't
that I I liked I like the idea of focus
umbrals and all that it's I feel a
little bit a little bit complicated it's
too many steps for no reason all right
so you got to do the hammer so you get
the charge then it is then you gotta go
there and then why why do I have to do
this extra step we got the um Rule and
then you got the pre-mat Prismatic
retaster it feels like there's too many
extra steps like this should be one and
then even the um the at the helmetal
reputation the more table reputation
it's not clear that you have to look at
the seasonal challenge thing so I'm like
why can't I click I want to unlock what
why can't and I'm like it would just
give me a u I wanted it
hard on the time gate it hurts when you
date when I sat there and I was on
stream alerted the first day I'm like
all right I'm making a video like what
am I doing well first one is leveling
okay second day what am I looking over
the hell because I was like this is a
mess to a point of like yep okay where
do you start and people are like what
like I put out a video over it I did not
know it was from the seasonal challenges
I'm like yeah most people won't because
it is not told at all here's the other
you're absolutely right it's not
explained well it it it's it's confusing
for no reason and then because he said
the thing that you need to get that is
in a separate area completely the thing
that USB nuts is the um now at the
focusing recaster thing right you know
how they got the tears they'd be like
okay you got to have 500 sniper kills to
do before you can unlock this part here
right why can't I track that outside of
the helm why do I have to go to the helm
to know where I'm at progress wise like
that is a problem like the UI this
season is a little I mean there were
some there are some UI cleanup which was
good yeah yeah
I back you up Cognito because I think
it's another one of those that that kind
of is like my if I had a topic sentence
it's like Bungie goes around the problem
because here's what's gonna happen I
think is they're setting it up so the
umbrella caster and the prism or
prismacrocaster and the umbrella engram
and all that other stuff that's gonna be
there every season this year so the
thing that's gonna change is the thing
that gets you there the seasonal
challenges and then all that other stuff
at the helm that's why they designed it
that way and yeah it's disparate it
doesn't there's a disconnect there
because what they're going to do is
they're going to rip out the the hammer
they're going to give us something
different next season and it's going to
be the knife of so the knife of lawn
mowing I don't know what it is
exactly and there will be like the seven
things and you'll unlock them and you'll
do and then you go and then there's the
new things that you that's it's another
one of those instead of creating a
single thread which makes sense right
they're gonna they're gonna again it's a
production it's a production cost thing
but that I feel like that's the reason
why and you're a hundred percent of the
money there my yeah
yeah and well that's point you know I'll
give it to you last one and then the
thing is I I know the artifact gets a
lot of craps of times
gotta be honest y'all like
I kind of like that you know hey I'm I'm
busting out bowls I got my bowl overload
I got I got sniper anti-barrier
like yo I could throw that on your bro
all right let me tell you right now
oh let me tell you what I'm doing it's
just it's like I don't even I'm not a
sniper at all like when sniper quests
come up I'll be honest y'all I don't do
them like when the door was like go in
the cruise I'm not doing that fan I'm
not a sniper I'm not good uh that's not
what Cognito does the best sniper you're
gonna get from me is whisper the worm
and I dreaded doing that remember that
like I that I'm not a son of God I will
say this with sniper on anti-barrier
I bust out that cloud strike fam yeah
I think I have my favorite I think that
is my favorite snake for the game like
with this perk and also Bo with the have
y'all used tikos with overload no of
course have you seen the madness this
thing is doing yeah it's fun that was
like the first thing I unlocked was that
straight away yes it's crazy it didn't
like you know it it is it forced
incentive to play with something yes but
let's be real as Destiny players we
stick in our rut of what is the most
effective and efficient and we will not
play these other archetypes and we're
like oh it's not good but the reality
they are good but you want to know
what's going to make me play other
archetypes though make fun weapons like
tikku's divination and you're gonna get
me to go play with other stuff
they made a lot of good web a lot of
good Exotics man lately they've been on
fire lately
like for me I always like it when
there's like a new thing like I haven't
messed around with Duality enough but if
you think about like Symmetry and some
of those other ones like I feel like
symmetry symmetries could actually be
fire in the next one but yeah you're
right about tiku because it's a lot of
fun yo T cool I haven't used a bonus
much in a minute man great you mean
concept it's like again like you're
setting something off while you're
throwing a little match
you use it different than anything else
you got the hip yeah it is the hip the
idiots the tag the explosion like it's a
fun little loop back and forth and it's
a little dance you do with the weapon
that's really really fun to do
PVP even the tag is like nine damage and
you're like not that much but if you hit
the head you get 137 twice and just boom
and I'm like that's fun yep I didn't get
a lot of them but I got a few of them
like these feel good feel good man
listen like at the look there's still a
lot of problems we know there's a lot of
resource thing going on like mono said
they're going around a lot of things
still
but I gotta admit this season so far is
far to me fun fun fun now granted it's
early
week five right now but generally with
the way seasons have gone
I kind of like let's be real when we saw
Wrath of Lord hunts you did the first
round you were like oh yeah we know what
type of season this is if this is the
content yeah
yeah you got to see it early and we know
we get two more Battlegrounds One's
Gonna Be On cosmet room one I'm pretty
sure it's gonna be
still think I think I know where that
one's gonna end up but we'll have to say
I think it's gonna be buried in that
nessus cave but right
um but yes like it's
it's more than hunts which is a low bar
it's match made it's already better
there because you're doing stuff with
other people you get the chance to like
and as you said late so far the two have
a different feel and I hope they keep
that going because when you're in the
Europa one at the end I've never seen so
many Phalanx in one area life
yeah I just reloading real quick because
I don't know if the stream died or what
but yeah it says network error it says
reconnect okay yeah it's attempt to
reconnect so we'll come back
um
well as it's trying to reconnect
apparently
continue
uh basically for me it's just the idea
that I will be curious how they
hopefully make the Battlegrounds have
some difference because you did you guys
did say it like the nessus one you know
you're climbing up the hill Europa
you're going down I wonder how it's
going to feel like the cleansing
Battleground for cosmodern that's like
are you going to be going through the
mouth yards to wherever that goes I
forget where it is like I wonder how it
is gonna progress those things and I I
Gotta Throw a little beef at the at the
destiny 2 designers here because like oh
I I almost say is like they set up and
they talked about hey we're gonna bring
back the cosmodrome and like we're gonna
start adding pieces to it and then they
actually talked this week about we
didn't set your expectations right
and I'm like guys you can't do that dude
you cannot do that you have to open that
area up just open it up open the door
it's already made like just put it in
there and put it in in the cosmodrome
because I think that's that's my beef
there is like you you literally said
we're gonna add more stuff to cosmodrome
and now they actually like we're not
gonna add anything else to the
cosmodrome like all they got to do is
open up that back area of the of the of
the mop uh is it the moth yards or the
the rail yard or whatever it is the
cosmodrome it's like the southern part
of it let's just open that up and that
should that should be an expectation
like because I agree I was very
disappointed when I read that yeah to me
I felt to be honest it felt dishonest a
little bit it's just like that's not
what was promised initially you know I
mean and and the other thing is where it
really feels bad we're absolutely right
now is that um you know the purpose they
said of the Vault was space and things
were getting too big and now you know
but then we could bring this old stuff
back and we could have it reimaged but
now you're not necessarily followed
through with that so it's just yeah it
doesn't feel good it doesn't I mean I
think that's showing more bandwidth than
anything yep yeah it's like it's the
idea of like that's why we keep coming
back and we've set up multiple like
episodes like how much of the studio we
know they lost that conversion we know
we lost multiple Studios we get that I
understand but again how much of the
internal piece of Bungie how much has
been shaved off to focus on D2 while
whatever else D3 matter correct yeah
correct how how divided are they because
like I was literally playing strikes
today just Vanguard strikes bugged out
multiple times couldn't even get through
a door couldn't finish another one I
could not throw the ball in the
corrupted on the final platform
I could not I hit her seven times of the
ball shield never went down over and
over and over and over and just bugged
and then I was with I don't know if the
other two idiots in the back were brand
new or what one kept trying to make a
jump and falling down and I saw his
buddy was waiting on him to rest him so
he was like jumping I see him fall I'm
like oh he rest jump fault res I'm like
either he's busted she's busted I had to
cut out that one I was like I was just
trying to finish my third Vanguard
strike just to pick up a picture
couldn't finish it damn couldn't finish
it yeah I'm seeing some little warts too
I've got some weird stuff because you
know cognito's all about his warlock
fashion so what happens is I was ready
to um I had like an outfit you know me
you know I'm wasted upgrade modules just
to make sure every subclass has the good
outfit to match with the good Shader
anyway so I'm looking for a specific
ornament remember the dawning set and
the warlock's doing it is fire and I'm
like yo where is it and I could not find
and the rest of the set is there arms
leg but the helmet I'm like why is the
helmet missing then I looked at my no
time to explain ornament the Frosty one
yeah all right sorry I'm gonna take it
off a little bit I took it off why is it
just gone now forever it's gone yeah I'm
like so it's these little warts and then
you got the bug and then obviously we
just heard about what is it uh Fallen
saber now is I didn't even get a chance
to try it okay I was never in the game
oh okay okay that's another thing they
didn't tell us they knew it was bugged
and they're like it took people like a
couple days and be like yeah it's bugged
it was people were getting locked out of
doors sounds like some of the stuff that
I'm facing right now but they didn't
even turn it on
yeah okay and it's literally on the
counter like here it comes there was no
warning like hey it's not whatever it's
literally just not there sorry for
everybody who is in stream by the way or
if this ever makes it out there because
I think we're disconnected right now
internet is having issues but we will
get out there on the Streamlight or on
video and stuff later on
no and I agree with you man like I just
I would rather than be honest and be
like yo it's because of covid we'll push
it back another like I feel like they
should fulfill that promise that they
say and like be like yo we're gonna
expand the cosmodrum and stuff
um and I think
it's kind of rap not rapid but just kind
of like put this pin out there for me I
feel like y'all y'all seen The Dark
Knight right so it's that point it's
that part where the Joker's like talking
to Batman and he's like dude I know the
truth like everyone looks back at D1
with this with these weird rose-colored
glasses like you know things want to go
people want to go back to the way things
were and it's like I know the truth
we're never going back there like it's
never gonna happen like we're never
gonna get back and I think that that is
one of the the mishaps of the game is I
feel like people keep wanting to go back
to this magical time of like this was
this is when everything was great
because to be honest with you the only
time I would say that Destiny was at its
peak like the bestest and he was taking
King yes followed by maybe the launch of
Rise of iron which was which was great
and I love the whole Narrative of the
iron Lords and Saladin oh love it but
I don't think we're ever gonna get back
to that if we keep pulling that stuff
back like I think we need to do that's
the new thing is like we need to do
something and we need to commit on it
and I hope I pray that
and it's like when Luke Smith says you
know why do you want to Destiny three I
wanted Destiny 3 because it will
automatically Sunset all your stuff it
will give you a whole new campaign it
will give you all these other things
that you're trying to create
synthetically by Sun setting because
that's what it is you're essentially
synthetically sun setting or creating a
new game so I'm hoping that we'll have
Destiny 3 and the I think that the the
lore or the or the the the notes back in
Destiny one is that there should have
been the old swamp of Old Chicago yeah
um
um and then the whole thing with the
winner because the truth is is we're
really not engaging with the black Fleet
at all it's here but I hope not really
yeah yeah but it's not really and I
don't feel like they can really really
connect us with that whole story if they
don't come out with a destiny three if
they don't come out with a destiny 3 and
they just do an expansion it's like okay
I guess the Black fleet's coming out now
I don't feel like they can really do it
unless if they have a full-fledged full
new game because you've got to have that
moment of and I'm hoping that something
like this happens like where we lose our
light again and the only thing that we
have is the darkness and then we kind of
have to like fight back to get to the
light that would be a compelling story
that'll be fire yeah yeah and then that
that I feel like that's what we need but
there's too much I think you said is
yeah and like what I said was uh going
around the problem so but this season
has been fun so far I like I'm looking
forward to playing it after we're done
like I got this my Friday and Saturday I
got 4 four day weekend so nice nice so
I'm gonna I'm gonna play a lot and make
some content and stuff like that so yeah
I mean like I said I mean I agree with
pretty much everything you guys have
been saying you know it's um I firmly
believe there's going to be a D3 at some
point I think everything right now is
just stop Gap who knows if it's like a
um
live team situation with D2 card like we
don't know what the current bandwidth is
actually working on the game versus
working on the new IP versus working on
potentially a D3 or whatever so you know
we got to see um like I said early one
week but I I do love the start I love
the star yeah I love the infusion of the
weapons I love you know everything
that's been included from the chase so
I've been good I've been good so far I
was going to see how it continues you
know what I'm saying as long as I keep
getting that narrative beat then I'll I
will continue to be kind of invested so
that's where I'm at with it right now I
mean we said that before I think we were
talking about like are we gonna see the
pyramid ships are we gonna see this
other race and we're like for an
expansion we said we hope not or at
least I know we've said that before is
because to introduce and introduce a new
race you have to do them Justice and
it's like at that point it has to be
substantial changes new whole bunch of
stuff not just like take some planets
away here as a plan and if that's all
we're getting is that Exchange now
like what's coming okay so we're gonna
get something with witch Queen where
we've got some who knows what it's gonna
be for her what's gonna leave then
right how much more is Gonna Leave This
game that you started playing this thing
with when you finally get to the point
where like hey new light player you're
four years into the game you can't play
the old stuff and that's the thing like
I haven't played Final Fantasy 14 but
the fact that I know it started brutal
they literally turned it off rebuilt it
started back again and it was called
like reborn or something they rebuilt
the game and you get to that point where
it's like you people now like you have I
swore hundreds of hours of game in Final
Fantasy 14 before you get to the current
stuff but they still get to experience
it all there is no more red War there is
no more curse of Osiris there is nothing
to let you experience what's already
been there just like hey here's shahan
okay we have uh kaito right now like you
just are thrown in so quickly and it's
something as big as the pyramid ships as
you said they like kind of phased out
some of the solar system you're like all
right
what's happening with that like and it's
like that was the big ending to a season
and okay we are gonna go take care of
the darkness over here where we can
still get to it but that other stuff
we're not going to talk about that for
like a year except Pro is gonna whistle
that's it
and I feel like you know you said it
Cognito and it's one of the lines we
want to create a single evolving world I
feel like the only way to truly do that
is to make a third experience not a
third expansion like a destiny three
because I feel like a lot of people are
probably gun shy of it because because
here's here's my thing about the launch
of Destiny 2 the destiny that so many
people are like I don't want a relaunch
of a game I think that they're looking
at it the wrong way and the reason why
is because the campaign of D2 was
amazing it was it was fantastic that was
the way it should have been yes the
problem was we had all these awesome
systems from Destiny one and we as a
community assumed that those systems
would come in and fill in the end game
of Destiny of Destiny 2 and that was the
problem now here's the thing if we can
have a destiny 3 and they take all the
systems that they've built and all the
things and we have the grand Masters and
we have all these other things that we
expect as a community it will work it
will not only work it will it will
absolutely just be amazing right but
they can't do the thing that they did in
D2 where they're like we're gonna
simplify everything it's this basic
story
here's the two little things and and
then we're done and that's it like it
cannot be that that's what the community
I think and a lot of people who say I
don't want a destiny three yes you do
everyone who's it's true because be like
a lot of people are like I don't want to
Destiny three why would I want to lose
all my guns why do you want to use the
same guns for four years because they're
they're basically what's the line most
people don't actually know what's good
for them you know people don't you know
it's that effective yeah I agree I agree
so anyway yeah no no I think I think
you're right I think I mean me and Eve
said this you know at nausea at times
because at the end of the day you know
the player like you said sometimes
doesn't realize what they actually you
know doesn't know what they want but the
main thing to me is you know
there's a lot of the business aspect
that's still involved that I feel is
holding back the creative aspect the
design aspect and when you're still
having to design for a base Xbox One and
a base PS4 that was the other thing I
forgot about that right at the end of
the day there is constraints and
limitations to how what you can do
because at the end of the day this game
still has to be played at the lowest
common denominator yeah 900p 30 frames
per second on the old like it's the
thing yeah exactly exactly so it's like
at the end of the day it's like to me
did that this is where the business
sometimes gets in the way and the
resources the lack of resources gets in
the way and this is where D3 now you do
a hard cut and it's like okay next gen
only PC yeah right fresh new engine here
we go and like you said Remember the
starter d2's campaign
you know what's amazing because they had
they were implementing things classic
budget stuff like that but now just
retain the things that we've liked these
two of the things that we know that
worked yeah and then add on these new
systems and then maybe you could do
those expansive rumors that we heard
remember the the PVE versus VP Zone all
these rumors that we had heard that were
cooking up and now you have maybe a
story with light you know you've
completely lost it you're in the dark
you can really expound and without
limitation it's pretty much what I'm
trying to get at and I think that's the
problem right now because to me like you
said Mano this is the holding on oh
we're gonna Sunset oh you know we're
gonna we're now we're gonna do cross
play like they're still holding on
they're not ready yet that to me that's
what if I was like they're not ready
we're gonna put a little Band-Aid here
we're gonna drip feed you along
you know what I'm saying and then when
we eventually right I do agree it is
going to happen yeah it just it just got
pushed back did that that's the vibe I
got and I I feel like that too you know
for me it's one of those things where
you know
from just a narrative standpoint it just
makes sense and it just makes sense to
like just have like the black Fleet be
the thing because I don't feel like
because whatever's going to happen with
Sabbath moon is going to happen but we
can't just have one year of the pyramids
and be done with Destiny I don't know I
don't think that Destiny 2 can end with
lightfall or whatever they're gonna come
with I can't
my question like if you think about like
a production value and you talk about
investments from a production side of
things you know there were you're right
is like you're building all these
systems for cross play why are you going
to build a cross-play system for game
for a game of content that's only going
to be for another fresh for another year
see my wonder about that cross play
system as some people have owner it's
like how many people are working on
Destiny 2 is this cross-play system
technology for them to use somewhere
else is it Destiny 3 is it matter is
this being built as a system
functionality piece for the okay we
understand how crossplay works we have
the servers the setup the code whatever
it may be and is Destiny 2 like the tool
to get it out to get it built it'd be
weird and I hope that's I'm with you
it's like if lightfall if sabathoon
somehow comes
somehow there's connection her the
pyramid ships whatever and then all of a
sudden we turn around lightfall as you
said like lightfall how else can you
read that theoretically besides like
light fall traveler goes bad traveler
goes in hiding we lose our light we lose
our touch with whatever maybe our ghost
is still with us but our ghost is with
the darkness so we're kind of there
right like how could you go one year and
just cut like
so I'm with you it's like it's got to go
bigger and this is that's why I was like
when I look at this point I'm looking to
witch queen I'm looking yeah these
Seasons right now are
I'm along for the story Journey the guns
are going to be their game the gameplay
is going to be kind of good but I mean
if you look at the the calendar I said
this last week and I kind of gave it a
harsh tone but week one two
Battlegrounds week two Battleground week
three battle green ground week seven or
eight I forget the math strike
week like 12 Guardian Games and you go
like one two three seven twelve done
like there's a lot of space now we know
there's one other thing if you look at
the press kit we'll talk about that
towards the end but that's still one so
again how
and this kind of takes me back to when
it comes to the helm and this is kind of
coming back into how things are when you
look at the helm and you're like cool so
here's all these things I can upgrade
there's one on the bottom left there's
two down there one every time you smash
the hammer it costs more which I don't
know how much it's gonna cost yet even
if it's double it costs more but you get
two charges so it's like even if it's 28
for two your time's been in
Battlegrounds now is half as much but
how long is it going to take me to get
there I went capacity first I went the
other direction
go this way so if I go one two three
four then maybe I don't need Max
Capacity then I head back this way and
then I go down that's like one two three
four it was a month away before I can
even touch that I can't just like I
can't put the time in to grind it out
it's just a forced time gaining of even
like and this is like by the time I get
the hammer completely unlocked The
Season's gonna be half over if not more
yeah and then I'm sorry okay no and
that's and that like I sat there and I
went through that math I'm like oh oh it
just did not leave a good taste in my
mouth just for how
they force you to go week after week
after week after week after week after
week I didn't like at all I know that
part I gotta agree with you that's the a
big negative because I'm like okay once
I figured out this convoluted mess of oh
the requirements are in this challenge
section
that's completely not next to you know
that the UI doesn't show me right next
to the war table but okay fine then I'm
like wait a minute there's only like
three or four of those and I did them
already
and where's the rest so I can advance
this week two weeks three week four like
yeah I was like yeah you trying to hold
me now now you holding me hostage
yeah holding me hostage I like that
that's great that's actually a kind of a
scary way to put it
well like a gaming hostage because I
mean they're so afraid of people going
and play like I it's one of those things
that I feel like they have to like
sometimes I feel like people who look at
data right because like very animal I'm
not an analytical person I'm more of
like a big big picture thing because
there's some people who are super into
the data points the problem is is that
data can be convoluted into almost
thinking anything so if they're like oh
our player base needs to stay at this
number well let's look at the data and
see what people are actually doing so
let's double down on that the thing is
is that it's it's like oroboria or or
the snake eating its own tail like it's
self-fulfilling prophecy is like if you
double down on these things people are
going to spend more time playing these
things right right and so that's one of
the things is like people they're not
like super invested in Trials I still
don't feel like even though they've got
like the new armor and stuff like that
because the PVP we should talk about the
PVP community at some point too because
that's a big sticking point yep
um but they're like well we see most
people are playing strikes and not is a
ton of people are playing Gambit so
we're not going to do anything for
Gambit and Gambit is this basically the
same thing we got two years ago go yeah
and I'm just like dude you can't because
I actually I actually love gambling I
actually like it yeah yeah but the
problem is is like where's the new maps
like where's the new app maps where's
the new like why don't we have a map on
Europa same thing with PVP I and I'm
gonna and I'm gonna throw a little shade
because like they're so good at what
they do I'll throw a little shade I know
people who can design a map for a game
we used to do it in Halo right I didn't
play a lot of Halo but I even know you
used to be able to design maps and stuff
for it
there are people who could design those
Maps like we could have a community map
designer or whatever like there are
people who would gladly people who love
Gambit that would design it and I don't
feel like it would be that I agree
intensive yeah no I agree and again I
listen I'm not a person
that the way I judge a person is I don't
look at I don't listen to what someone
says yeah
I look at what you do you know and for
me
since they have been so I say this ad
nauseam they are telling us with their
actions they are not capable this
company is too competent to not know
right that we are upset about lack of a
map and lack they are too confident I am
never going to disrespect them in that
way because I know they know they get
down to okay we got this little bucket
of water here and here are all these
fires yeah what are we going to address
now this week
that's all this is because again what
the only thing they did say that I took
their aware from and I as I say it again
you're never gonna get an expansion like
forsaken again no it hit me I was like
damn we can't get that ever yeah we
never gonna get that you know what I'm
saying so I'm like yeah and and now this
is where I come back to eat and I'm full
circle with e because I know he's
frustrated this is where I'm back with
him now is that again you look at the
background you look at you look you look
at that map you look at okay
other than the Battleground stuff
you know which is less it's fun it's
mindless it's shooting I am like 12
weeks of Battlegrounds everybody's gonna
run to the end of the Rope at that
you're like week four week five cool
I've seen them I get it I've smashed a
few hammers I'm checking out right like
again so that it comes down to this is
the drip feed this is the the hostage
situation we don't got nothing just hold
them off all right what about you know
what I'm saying that even the even the
war table I do that's what I knew it was
bad because even Europa we did homeboy
varex right
his table
you could dig down from the very
beginning remember with Europa you could
do it you know this Explorer one if you
kept going and you kept you could do it
I'm like why is this a three to four
week weak thing and I gotta come back
next week and I can't I want to do this
like why can't I do this so that part
really expounded I'm like wow it's yeah
yeah this is they're trying to hold us
back because they know we are going to
blaze through this in no time and this
is artificial this is if artificial
investment that's just what it is well
this is this is this is kind of
connected to that and I think that
that's a problem that they need to
address I know the drip feed content is
where they live but at the same time
like
it's one of the things that upsets me as
a content creator and like sometimes
like when you're trying to be in front
of stuff everything is data mined so
like they have everything set up to drip
feed like they've got the you know
talking about like a bucket of water in
terms of like like putting out like
fires but if you think of it like like a
like a drip like there's here's the
water for the season and they put it in
there's someone like who is gonna find
out all those files because it's on PC
and
it there's no surprises anymore because
no matter what you can go on to Reddit
and so the drip feed content and the
anticipation and stuff that we build and
you know you can't stop people from
doing that like if you're gonna do drip
feed content it if you put all the stuff
and all the code in the game they're
gonna find out if there's a reason we
know about hawkmoon like months in
advance there's a reason we already know
and I don't want to spoil everyone right
now what's coming we are what the only
things that we don't know is the stuff
that they don't put in the game and I
feel like they need to have like a
weekly I know that it's resource
intensive but if they don't
if they don't put the stuff into the
game until they update it and like then
you actually like see it where that
would be amazing because then we
wouldn't have all this stuff this stuff
spoiled because every person's gonna
click on that thing you know oh yeah
every person is gonna be like
you know that's why everyone knew what
was going to happen with
um with uh
the crow like months in advance is
because they leaked it like two months
ago and it's like well there's the
season bye so and that stuff so I always
wonder is like yeah PC is a problem now
because they didn't have to worry about
that on Console but console you have
like you know certification for
everybody and if they have to do like
certification every week for like
updated stuff for a little while then
that gets to be I don't know what that
does for them on the business side or
how what the implications are for
another code like let's certify all this
stuff and then we got a little hotfix
cool throw that out there for a fix or
this one this but the big stuff we got
to make sure it's all square
send it as one and unfortunately PC gets
it too and that's PC is when all this
stuff started and there's only so much
they can do but that's the piece why
like when as you said they hold you
prisoner to like every week I gotta now
granted the seasonal challenges
I swear it's like are gonna get a bad
vibe in my head because in theory it's
like outriders demo it's gonna come out
in two weeks and I'm like sweet I'm
pumped I'm really excited I'm gonna die
like I'm going
into that one because all your progress
is going to carry forward so I can play
every character you have like all that
stuff I'm gonna play that for a while it
might take a couple weeks off I'm just
like full on outriders make all the
content I can there's gonna be a gap
before it comes out in April cool
whenever I come back on week five I can
go back through those weeks of
challenges
but I also can't pre-work it right now I
can't be like I've got time right now I
can't grind the crap out of it for the
next week take a break prep for
outriders do that I have to do it on
their schedule I can't make it here's
your here's your season no no it's like
here's a little bit here's a little bit
and I said it before it's like reading a
book one page it's like you used to get
like one page in the mail shows up in
your mailbox every day oh cool I got
this one you're gonna finish the book in
a year and you can't go faster no matter
what you do about it yeah
and it's like the story the drip free
the upgrades the drip when I looked at
the table I think the war table hit me
the hardest just the hammer enhancements
that one yeah yeah I did I did you know
and I think we as a culture too like
remember you know you talked about this
Cognito is like check out next time next
Saturday morning we're gonna have the
next episode and we don't live in that
age anymore and they're trying to live
come this week you know come this week
this is the next episode come this and
no one does that everyone gets the
Mandalorian you wait until the only
difference would be one division
I've been checking out on division it's
amazing I gotta get to it it is legit
like it's a it's it's really good and
like I would say once you hit like
episode four and five you're like dude
yo
I haven't watched the days but so far
it's like the first couple because I had
friends were like what is happening they
didn't make it through like the first it
was like I was like come on just like
little face little faith and then like
okay all right paid off okay all right
now I'm like literally just like hold
done by the only thread at the end of
the episode I'm like come on I want to
know what's behind the curtain and like
that's cool because they're building
stuff and telling a story this one
typically the problem with like Destiny
especially in the seasons how much story
do we actually get throughout the season
right we get it at the beginning and we
usually get like a wrap up in the end
and maybe like one little bit in the
middle but it's not the story is
typically not tied and that's why I
think that middle six week seven week
where it's at for the strike may have
story implications between now and then
why are you like forcing us to be like
on that Cadence be like here here's a
noise another story beat here and you
could unlock some more stuff but not
just like a little bit every just do it
in bigger chunks so there's some
flexibility to it yeah and I think
Cognito you said it right like it is
cool to catch the lines like I when I
listen to that line I like was smashed
my chest at the end and I'm like okay
cool and it's starting to mess around
with dim just to check and see my
Loadout and stuff again and then I heard
the lines and I'm like whoa you're
talking about efforts
that was cool that was cool yeah I liked
it again
if they're going to drip feed which is
where we're going this is where this is
what it is this is the no vicarious the
no Activision the no High Moon Studios
flow this is the we're working at man on
matter and possibly D3 like at the same
time and this is how we you know what
what should we see in the helm I knew I
was all about it it's really bad is it
they tried all they putting out all the
stops right now to hold us back so if
you're gonna do it I'm gonna be okay if
I get those types of interactions and
get that type of Engagement with the
with the narrative law because at least
it it it's helping drive it along a
little bit as far as I can tune in and
hear what these relationships are but
for a guy like e you know I mean I I get
them I feel them he's like yo
you know how much engage am I going to
really be with two more Battlegrounds or
whatever whatever and that's the
question you know and it's a tough one
it's a tough one because I I do I do
sympathize with him and and I sympathize
with them it's a tough thing because
it's like yeah until they figure out
how they want to move with Destiny
moving forward
we're gonna be here for a while yeah
we're gonna be here guys I'm just I'm
just telling y'all like this is what
it's gonna be and and I get it a lot of
people don't want to hear it they don't
want to they like look I pay as much
money for this game I put so many hours
in this game you know they need to
change the structure or I'm out you know
yeah and then it's going to be a
situation where I think we've seen
examples of I believe it was cathallion
or someone who's made an example like
look seasonal battle is just not for me
it's just not for me you know as a
hardcore guy you know I'm only coming in
for the Beyond likes to Shadow keeps the
whatever you know what I'm saying and
that's where it's at and then I'm also
seeing this weird Cadence where the
season that's tied to the expansion is
always ironically the weakest always
weak like because they know they can
crutch on it a little bit they can just
get the expansion and I think part of it
too is that they also want to make it
you know you mentioned like you got to
make it though I shouldn't say the
lowest common denominator but you have
to go to you know the person who can
invest the least amount of time and you
don't want to leave them behind right
and that's the majority that's the
problem that's that's the bigger base
because again they're Captain analytical
they're looking at the numbers they're
looking at the game pass they're looking
at the PlayStation 5 60 frames per
second and that's where all the majority
of the bass is whereas you may have a
hardcore section of the PC and that the
content creators and stuff like that
it's they're in a tough spot man I do
not envy them but continue man I'll
catch you I'm sorry no that's I mean
that's that's it exactly is it's I think
it's one thing to
they are smart enough I mean any human
being can read Twitter and I know
sometimes Twitter can be like a can be
kind of a cesspool yeah I mean I mean
I'm being nice I only get on Twitter
because I'm a content creator like if I
didn't if I was the content creator and
if I didn't know I would yeah it's a
good way to connect with people
especially with you guys
um but the other stuff is like I would
never go onto Twitter because I feel
like some people you know it can be a
real oh it is not representative of what
most people are thinking and I think
that's what some people think they think
this is the world and it's not but
anyway like they are you're right
they're too smart they're too competent
like you don't have to be super Advanced
to understand that these problems exist
within the game I think that I love that
idea of like I've got this much water I
got to put out these fires I love that
that's great
um and I mean the PVP Community is one
of those things that I am definitely I'm
definitely feeling about and I I I I
don't I wouldn't say I'm a PVP man I
enjoy PVP when there's nothing else to
do do
um but I really feel for them because
like we haven't had any new iron Banner
gear and I love Iron banner I love I'm
weird because I love Iron Banner a lot
of my a lot of the other people I play
with don't like Iron Man I like Saladin
I like the whole idea of it
um you know there's some Nostalgia for
me because one of my other videos they
kind of launched me a little bit was
like one of my first it was like the
fifth iron Banner that they ever did I
put a video out about I was like oh cool
and then I liked all the ornaments and
gear and stuff but we haven't had new
iron Banner gear in three years this is
the this season stuff like another
throwback too somebody already got some
of it yeah that's what I thought it's
already it's just the same stuff and I'm
like guys yeah you have to do something
different and I I will say the rise of
iron like that was actually one of my
favorite things about rise of iron is
the iron Banner gear yeah it was
so good it was so good the guns looked
awesome yeah
with the fur and the thing and then you
had the fire chests and the things and
the big elaborate ornaments and yeah
yeah they can make that stuff
it depends on where they put it now yeah
that's the thing is and I I want to
believe I want to believe like you guys
said that they're that they're waiting
on something and that they're pushing it
they're investing in matter and maybe a
destiny three so you need to they need
to call Microsoft bam yeah I need to get
boy I think that they yeah I think that
they need to be like to either like team
up with another crew but make it so that
make it so that there's not creative
control because you're no matter what if
you go if you go with a bigger company
and you team up with them they're always
going to try and get a big piece of the
pie but the thing is is that I think
Microsoft especially if they could be
like hey we need some teams for this
like Microsoft has got teams they've got
gaming Studios if you could somehow
connect it without you know bringing
back because you got to remember like
Microsoft and Bungie that was Halo that
was Halo yeah that was the moment for
everyone for a lot of people with these
games is is that idea and uh I think
that if they team up without it being
like a creative control structure thing
right I think that they could do great
things and that they couldn't like
actually invest in the game that they
want yeah I don't think that stasis like
in the PVP Community I don't feel like
stasis I think it's I think it's a
symptom of greater problem like a lot of
people really don't like stasis because
of the whole idea of being frozen and
they're not wrong it's essentially like
a trapping mechanism right but if you
think about it it's the same thing as a
smoke bomb it's just like enhanced smoke
bomb
so
I mean stasis is not going anywhere I
can tell you they didn't spend like an
entire expansion no aspects fragments
you're like remove stasis from PvP I'm
like
I'm not a PVP player so I understand the
sweat Lords are like this doesn't feel
good but I can promise you from Bungie
sick it's not going anywhere it's going
anywhere just be like there's no way
that's gonna happen yeah I've been
having a ton of fun with stasis and PVE
all right you did something amazing I
like I I got a couple loot builds now
only thing is the warlocks bro we we got
we got I think they said they said
something they said something on Twitter
that then it's broken not working the
way it's supposed to hold on let me look
it up yeah that turret is garbage that
turret is so bad like
it was like standing right in front of
him and it's like not doing anything
just like oh the concept of it is cool I
was like oh Tory I play games like that
where you defense games even a little
turret out there like yeah not this one
this one is just when you get a mark
buddy stasis no how did they say
somebody said you could have um
tweeted two hours ago go we confirmed
that penumbrals blast damage being
reduced was not an intended change and
will be fixed so I mean I feel feel my
warlocks my warlock yeah I I almost feel
like to solve it for PVP it's not to
take stasis out of the game it's to do
another one of those it's an enhanced
it's an enhanced smoke bomb so you don't
freeze people like the thing is is when
you remove player agency yeah then that
doesn't feel good so I feel like if they
used it as a slowing mechanic only and
they didn't allow you to freeze anything
right um to freeze people I think that
that would solve a problem but again I'm
an armchair developer so you know I'm
with you because like when it like the
dusk-filled grenade or something I got
slowed basically but I didn't get killed
I think somebody like a hunter hit me
with one melee and I was slowed but I
managed to kill them still like rare yes
okay this sucks it's like they use their
ability it's like but I managed to get
like the final hit cool but it's like
when you're just like
trapped when you're a statue ass because
you're just like
I think you guys know that once just by
pure luck they got me and I saw somebody
kill and I'm like cool
because I can't turn my face but yeah
Cognito I think you got it right on the
money I think you keep that freezing
mechanism in PVE so you feel strong and
PVE and then you take that like if you
get hit by like the great Glacier nade
like it slows you down like you just get
the dusk field slowing down effect right
so you at least have the ability to move
in some way I think that'll make pvps
but a PVP feel a lot better but then
they would have to separate the sandbox
and that's right yeah
they could do I mean it's just I think
it's a battle they're not gonna you know
try to for whatever they've gone at it
this long the thing is look I've been
playing I played a ton of PVP I've
played a lot of I played a lot of this
season
I'm morally what's your life by the way
what's y'all like let me see where y'all
at with your lights
something like that okay yes I'm close I
meant
1291. yeah he's kidding yeah
so it's like and I played a ton of um
what is it Glory yeah
right it's the best way to level up a
great way to level up oh man so like
playing that shout out to Forte shot the
citizens they were rocking and you know
it didn't feel like PVP felt good I mean
the only thing about stasis right now
that I have a problem with I felt they
they've they've neutered the dust
grenade dust feel finally into a that I
feel it feels somewhat fair that I could
shoot back and I could at least get out
of it a little bit better than before
the issue I have now is with the
freezing stuff on controller it still
feels awful trying to get out of it it's
like oh tap the right analog two times
and I'm like now I heard I think they
updated where you could change the
escape button or something yeah and I
actually don't like that because they
won't let you because it used to be you
held down your class ability right and I
like I'm actually not a huge fan of that
and I play keyboard I play both but now
I'm starting the main keyboard and mouse
right
um and I don't like the fact like I have
to change my keybinds now because they
won't let you put it on your class
ability it will not it will not tag yeah
and it doesn't feel good on PC either to
your mouse and keyboard
[Music]
there's something still off about the
escaping and the Damage when you escape
it's still that part with the with the
hard freeze that that I still struggle
with that but overall everything else
like now I mean outside of there's a
couple of things man that Titan thing I
got man with that slide to the thing oh
my God
I didn't really I mean they're gonna
tune that too because that's the Titans
were using that back in the day I would
argue that if you know how to do it
Titans with shotguns at close range Maps
they're so good oh this is how far you
can yeah that's crazy because you can
shotgun anyone from like any distance
like you could be a mile away and you
just film across the map you get I mean
I'm not gonna lie
once or twice let me tell you the
disgusting thing I had to face it in uh
Glory Crucible was a couple of Titans
with that and Duality because Diwali
also got on a buff on distance
it's more than Phil Winter's lie y'all
that like the guy what's that map uh
burning Shrine you know I was just in
the center there's the corridors that's
separated by the Gap when you're inside
yep I was on the other side of the
shrine okay and the guy was running
towards me hadn't made the jump over yet
he slid to the edge of his side of the
ledge do I lead me and killed me I said
how how could this man raged me this far
and I was like what was what gun was
that and I was like oh no Duality with
that thing scary so yeah there's a
couple of combinations and I'm like oh
boy that's gonna be a little man but for
the most part I still been enjoying PVP
yeah you know I'm saying I still I still
enjoy things I've been messing around
with the with the new aspects of the
fragments I didn't think we were going
to get too many of those but I got some
new stuff while working out and just you
know we just got to get that warlock
turret fixed and then everything else so
fine you know what the new meta is
though the new meta that's coming out
and if you're a warlock this is gonna
make you happy everyone when you're
running in like high-end comp because of
the way the only way to fight stasis if
you're a warlock unless if you're doing
even top tree dog blade is a little
tricky in close Corners everyone is
running chaos reach with geomag
stabilizers oh [__] and so when I would
go up and I used to see a lot of stasis
when I went into cop and did the glory
and the glory playlist and stuff like
that yeah the first couple ones I've
been do I've been seeing Phil teams of
people using chaos reach and it's
because it's the only way to do it and
you get your super back so quickly
um and now if you've got um there's some
things you where you can get your super
back really quickly you have a high
intellect build and you just consist
consistently do that and pop that it's
gonna be really good because
um like the community is gonna find the
best thing and if people are like I need
to find a way to fight stasis what
better way to fight stasis where you
have to kind of be close range sort of
that a giant laser beam
like that there's no other better way to
fight it so and it's one of the ones
that can output enough damage because
the annoying thing is all running around
on my Titan and I love hammers I still
do I can't tell you how many supers I
smashed with one hammer and they don't
die I'm like why do you take two why do
you always take two hammers I'm like
Direct Hit And even with the explosion
Hammer still not dead and then I'm dead
by that point because there's nothing I
can do but that laser is like too much
fast damage that makes sense yeah and
Incognito to your point I think that PVP
I think with guns we are at the oh yes
that is yeah we are I love the best
place we've ever been because snipers
are strong those are strong like
everything has its place the thing
that's actually kind of messing
everything up is just the imbalance
caused by abilities yeah so I hope they
don't retune it to like Destiny to the
original like where you get your super
once in a match if you realize that was
just too much yeah that was too little
the only thing though
I look I know 120s this is your time but
my only issue is you listen that thing
hits like a truck right my only issue is
that the range is it's hitting at now
yeah because this thing is not only
hitting the hardest but it's also got
probably the longest ranges out of all
the hand cannons so my only thing is we
need a little range reduction just got
yeah introduction just slight ways other
than that that's just me nitpicking for
the most part I'm happy with the weapon
meta like I I feel the weapon sandbox
for the most part is in a good place I
think some machines on at least on um on
Console they don't shake as much they
feel really much better now you know I
think uh side arms I still have a good
place
um 600 Autos I mean I I've used some of
them a couple of times a couple times it
was still good right now right now
though I got I care a lot of um 340s bro
oh three four that's why I can't wait I
gotta jump in Trials I heard messenger
it's the three boom and I'm not gonna
lie I need to get in there for the three
Desperado messenger are you kidding me
my favorite kind yeah my favorite gun
from I actually used to farm it was the
two it was the Hopscotch Pilgrim and the
messenger let's go let's go taking me
back I gotta do some trousers I saw a
couple people get like killing win
Desperado oh like the amount of perks on
something I will say like they like I
think it's the Gambit hand Cannon which
nobody can get like a good drop of
because it's so you got one uh you lucky
bastard uh I don't have them no because
it's a 120 and everybody's like oh this
is good 20 matches and not get one
because there is no good way to grind
that and that's again like they have two
of those in there but you're like people
are like I played 20 Gambit matches what
am I doing with my life I'm trying to go
after like one weapon
like a little bit more Direction in some
of those like World loot Bowl playlists
would be nice because yeah when you
throw it in like 30 other weapons Gonna
Hurt yeah the messenger
as much as I like pulse rifles anyway
even I might have to recruit a little
help I'd even told my brother I was like
I told my brother I was like we are
going to have to struggle through that
Bounty but we need at least one of these
things that's it I don't know if I can
um I don't know if I could recruit any
uh backpack help but yeah I'll just
in there I know areas I don't even know
if I want to put you between me and my
brother and trials and you're the good
one in the group with two I don't know
if your backpack has enough space you're
about to carry out one at a time yeah
he's like I need I need some side
assistance here yeah I need that
messenger bro I need that bro cause
listen
no time to explain that's like literally
my go-to for everything right now okay
the only thing that could compete is if
if a 120 got to drop with me first
then I gotta I gotta disengage because
he's gonna win but if we're even you
know what I'm saying I cannot come off
the square I think the Flinch is good
with the um what you call it with
snipers and stuff like that where um I'm
able to move them off square a little
bit and um yeah man I've been really
I've been really liking the matter I
mean obviously following just lies
running rough shot we know
which is arguably a lot stronger than
the city
um that's all this is the last season of
of that so A lot of people are going to
be trying to lean on their Steady Hand
rolls and stuff like that yeah
um but I think you're exactly right on
the money is just if you just tick the
range down a little bit just a little
bit yeah you don't need to Nerf Nerf the
gun you just make it so that it's not a
sniper rifle like that no matter what
we'll body everyone yes exactly and last
PVE tidbit
um what you call it um if you guys got a
god roll if you farmed uh crows
wrathable weapons that what is it
deafening whisper or something
definitely Whispers great oh the per the
grenade launcher
I use it in the uh second encounter it's
like my main go-to weapon of second
encounter of the deep Stone Crypt
because like what I do with my teams is
I'll be the operator and what's cool is
so many people's struggle with that if
you're up in space they struggle because
there's like no way to get to that
servitor if it's hiding except if you'd
use Daphne whisper and you just waveform
grenade just wave two or three of those
done and like I feel like the waveform
is kind of ignores opposite
um like uh element energy like it
doesn't matter like I'm using it in the
Battleground thing and it's all solar
you know guys with solar shield and wave
thing definitely whisper is just like so
what I'm taking out it's even taking
good chunks out of like orange bars I'm
yellow bars and I'm like yeah this thing
is really strong like really so I can't
wait I'm working on that I'm using that
a lot because I'm working on trying to
get the uh the breach load the the new
one the one yeah
any of y'all got in your tiku's Catalyst
yet I'm curious I'm trying I I just get
the level 22. and then like I'll
quadruple I guess but I'm like I'm on
the second like second set of objectives
and I'm about I'm done with the bottom
and I'm working on The Crucible and the
matches and I'm okay oh I want to try
and finish it this weekend if I can get
level 22 I'll burn through that okay
yeah what you were saying Mano I was
just saying I I really only started
playing with because I'm gonna make I've
got a couple of videos just be with how
busy my normal life had been I was gonna
do like like a bot just put out a really
good leveling guide I was gonna put out
something like that like a leveling
guide the fastest way to get Salvage uh
Salvage Salvo or whatever it is like
I've gotta wait I got it in a couple
hours I haven't played a lot but I've
been like trying to do that but I've got
a couple of those videos but um I
haven't really got to spend a lot of
time with that I totally got into it
like last night
um actually like going in and just
messing around in the Battlegrounds and
like talking about like the match like
the first time I shot it too I'm like
Okay match and like what you were saying
earlier in the podcast like I didn't
understand it until like it took me a
couple of tries and the cool like crime
kill yeah
[Laughter]
and I actually love Bose
um I actually
um for some of the things that I used to
do with the dungeons is I used to
primarily use bows
um so you and I like share that yeah I
have gone through every solo every solo
dungeon run that I've done oh I always
have used a bow for a good chunk of it
made me not every single encounter but I
can tell you every like whether it's the
end of Prophecy whether you're like
picking off the guys on the Boss run or
there's times I've used a bow in every
shadow Throne like almost the entire day
of my throw yeah and now Trinity ghoul
oh if you go Trinity ghoul in the pit of
heresy uh-huh the Chamber of suffering
oh my god with the Catalyst on Trinity
ghoul that room is a joke
it was amazing yeah can I say something
by the way
um
in shattered Throne I know there's loot
in pit of heresy for the love of God can
we please make those like a rotating
Pinnacle feature dungeon yeah
like I don't know are they dropping
powerful they're not dropping powerfuls
they're just dropping rolls but here's
the things like season yeah we both make
the ascentage we had made the ascended
Challenge videos like last night on
stream I went to go there are great
weapons and going back to Lord Cognito
in the love for Forsaken and my favorite
armor from all of Destiny 2 has been the
reverie dawn like I'm gonna get it
completely because now all the ascendant
challenge video or all the ascendant
challenges are good to go you'll get
fresh stuff from that shattered Throne
like I'm really excited to dig back into
that stuff even though it's not powerful
but I love that idea of having like
prophecy Pitta heresy like if you could
rotate that every week I know that's not
necessarily fair to those people who
don't have those expansions but maybe I
don't know maybe you do something
because that would be a cool way yeah I
agree because it's the way to get like a
feature be like if you're working on a
pinnacle every soft and like one of
those is a pinnacle just to give it yeah
because those are are some of my
favorite content they're doable by a
smaller group so you don't have to
organize a raid which is still fun but
it's like it takes less people even a
two-man fire team can't do those and
those are as close as some people may
get to a raid but if they're the less
incentive is there just kind of hurts
them right I agree how long have we been
preaching 100 of the money you know
rotating raid Pinnacle rotating against
dungeons right yeah okay right that's in
patch notes it's not really but
something is it coming like a future
season or here future I think I think I
think it says
he he wrote uh DMG wrote something about
like he wasn't supposed to be in there
but it's coming I feel like that'll be
like that moments of Triumph moment yes
or they rotate the raids and stuff like
that but the real question is that
before Destiny 3 or is that before
sabathune saw or the Sabbath Moon
expansion the witch Queen that's a good
point I don't know yeah we got to see
the last thing I'll say is um have y'all
been using um Skyward results oh like
yeah nobody's business in Battlegrounds
boy it's awesome it's awesome if you've
got the Catalyst and stuff it shreds
okay am I missing something Catalyst
just as rage right yeah yeah but it was
like it goes through I mean it's inside
barrier goes through the cabal shields
I'm literally like playing on three of
them like I don't barely have to aim I'm
just like move it holding it down and
generally moving around the screen be
like all right Peck over here over here
like it's like easy mode for the
Battlegrounds now if you got cabal yeah
Sky version South is like easy mode to
just in it the
I don't the slug shots hit pretty hard
pretty hard or you're like you're just
start pecking damn no matter what you're
hitting you're like that damage bar is
actually going pretty quick just keep
firing like that is my go-to for them
until I actually learn how to use tiku's
properly oh that's true too yeah I've
been working on just the Catalyst though
so that's why I've got to get anything
but yeah when I'm done tickers is just
too much fun that was so much fun
especially that one in Europa in that
last room
um it's Consolidated and Osiris talking
and Colossus just everything's wrong and
it's just so much and then that final
stand he does when he has that little
bit of energy he creates the boat and
then he puts all lagoons out it's just
nothing but cabal ever It's So Much
Madness on the screen right and if you
have tikos or you Prime and stuff and
you're blowing up people that's next to
each other I have so much fun with that
straight like that that little confined
space is so much fun but yeah man that
was something about I think even datto
talked about this and I like I don't
always agree with yado but like he a
hundred percent Nails this the reason
why everyone loves sepix is because even
though it's not a large strike there's
so many enemies yeah and it feels good
to kill him it just feels good to just
slay out and it yes what is it it's like
five rooms is that strike it's literally
like you go through the railway then you
go through that small little area where
all the hive and the Fallen come out
then you go to the big open area with
the tank and then your septics yeah you
just it's it's and I think you spoke to
it too is you feel that big open concept
that's one of the ideas I love about
Destiny one and you see the rock the the
ships the rocket ships that would go up
yeah like it's just a cool game space I
don't feel like clustered and like
tightened in it and there's it doesn't
matter if there's a damage mechanic
there's so many enemies to kill and just
feels good feels good I love the
overwhelming odds and like it feels like
they're really trying to smother you you
know even at the end you beat
it's like sometimes I feel like I'm
sorry because it's like oh there's this
one sniper who's gonna like ruin your
day and it's like one guy ruined my day
it's like that doesn't feel as good if
you get like pegged with one one sniper
at a grand master Knight fell pink
you're like oh as opposed to here's the
horde of enemies coming at you it's like
all right fight them off explode
everybody doing all those things run
over here it's like that feels and if I
do die on that one I'm like all right
that feels kind of Justified because you
know I got overwhelmed as you said even
data said he's like if I don't pay
attention I could get surrounded but
also when I pop my super and I see the
chain of like score numbers go off on my
screen it's just like you just exploded
20 guys here five over here so that's
when it's fun yeah yeah absolutely oh
yeah new rad set it too the brig in the
tank area I did not expect the big like
I was like I was like oh dude we gotta
bring it here there's two of them I
think it was like okay that's a fun
addition that's nice it'll be fun it'll
be fun fun when they do the grand
Masters and stuff like even though I'm
not a gosh I I'm not a huge how do I say
this I like the idea of grand Masters I
don't like the way that they've executed
it because because instead of there
being new mechanics or new things that
you have to overcome it's here's a wall
deal with it yeah like pretty much
here's a really really prickly wall that
if you look at it wrong it's gonna kill
you right and like if they would
redesign it like maybe the tank has a
shield with it and you have to kill the
two bricks first and then you have to
throw a thing at the shield like I feel
like there's so many extra little things
that they could pop in that they could
teach people because that's one of the
major things about raids especially
coming from like a raid and dungeon
Sherpa there's all these little cool
mechanics that could make it feel good
that already like we kind of have an
understanding of but the more
you know as a this is weird because as a
music teacher like until you put those
challenges in front of people they're
not gonna get good at it right so if you
constantly are just like well people
aren't good at it because you know the
corrupted strike they don't know how to
pass to each other well put it somewhere
else in the game and teach them how to
do it right you know don't let them
sneak by it like teach them and be like
you have to do this to do that people
understand the raids a lot better you
know well I mean that goes back to we
haven't said it yet but I did want to
shout out on this one before I even
completely forget about it but this goes
back to zero hour the two different
difficulties yes no but the like the two
different difficulties the normal and
the hard
that's a different feel as you go
through like the jumping puzzle is more
difficult that you got to go through the
the order that you
I don't know if you have to switch the
switches I forget you know better than I
do and then just the final release you
can run them the same you get you can
run the switches the same switches are
the same the only thing that's different
is the jumping puzzle yeah and then the
the burn
um
please bring it back at some point
please oh God please so I wanted to
shout him out because I know I said it
like in the intro and probably blew past
it but on a side note because I wanted
to say it yeah how many did you end up
with for total clears and a quick little
side note you have a very like
gentleman's agreement that you have an
asterisk that you share that record with
somebody which is awesome so it's a cool
story because I am just oh they added
heart I just I'm just looking at dungeon
report for the first time so like they
actually had an Harbinger because
they're actually calling that dungeon I
have 1072 clears of it so I am me and
soft soft
um soft was another guy who kind of
joined in the community
um we what happened was I started just
chasing it and I started helping people
Not only was it helping the stream but
it was an encounter I loved because it's
an encounter that there's a lot of
density to to it
um it's chaotic it's crazy if you have
to deal with it you have to it's it's
not something that you can just like oh
I'll just kind of forced my way through
you have to think your way through it
and so I found that I was getting a lot
of traction on YouTube videos and I
mentioned this in the notes for the the
stream you know esoteric and glad and
everyone else had all these great videos
back when like stuff was just broken
um and that was like when uh skull of
daira Ankara
Orpheus rigs were like insanely powerful
and so they'd have all these tutorial
videos and then it was two seasons later
and all of those strats were null and
voids like and a lot of people are like
I can't do this I'm using these videos
and I'm like you can't do that anymore
so I I just started getting on my Titan
and like I just felt like a really good
vibe with it
um and I just started running them and
people enjoyed it I made it kind of a
hype show and it's something I hope I I
hope at some point I can kind of bring
back to the stream
um and maybe I can do it with Harbinger
but Harbinger doesn't quite feel the
same yeah he's like when I'm in the box
like usually I would carry people
because everyone struggles on the
jumping puzzle right and for me like I
just fly by it I don't even think about
it anymore skip half of it I saw which
is impressive yeah you can skip you can
skip the uh yeah because especially in
the hard mode if people are struggling
with it when they did a couple of the
Nerfs uh to a couple of things using
that would help you to get through more
and so that skip that was uh right
before the hangar Bay there was a skip
you could go underneath and basically
skip the area and what it does is it
unlocks all that stuff now I don't often
cheese stuff but because at the time
everyone really wanted to get that
weapon everyone wanted to make sure and
I mean because they knew they were going
to take it away and they still they
still haven't yeah headless yeah all
those people who I helped like I feel
good about because like at least I got
him the Catalyst they maybe they didn't
unlock the Catalyst completely but they
could finish it now but
um anyway I just started doing it I love
the encounter I think it's I think it's
one of the best Encounters in Destiny 2
history like it up there with Riven like
it's it's not overly thoughtful but if
you understand how the encounter works
and like how the tanks spawn and what
gets what what constantly spawns enemies
and how to deal with all the different
Shields like it's an amazing encounter
so and I love it I think it's better
than whisper but I know some people have
a lot of love for us Whispers music
though Whispers music like in the in the
uh the the oh and I I didn't throw that
out with the uh the music the piece of
music music
yeah 100 but
um the way that the gentleman's
agreement worked is there was a guy and
I'll actually have to look it up at some
point is like to just to look at zero
hours is there was a guy who had like
all these that it literally just ran
normals and was helping people through
and I just said a set of gold I was like
I'm gonna be number one in the world of
doing this and I've got all this time I
spent all my time streaming do this
there was another guy named soft who was
coming up and I reached out he Reach Out
to me I was like yo I'm gonna go for
number one and he also wanted to go for
number one too and he's like I just love
this I love this encounter and it was so
cool because you know I talked about how
the encounter is so unique
he had a completely different way of
doing it like I had my strats and stuff
like that and it's so so telling because
he had he had this charged with light
build with a sunbreaker and I did it he
was running it faster than I was and I
was like damn and he showed me how to do
it and he showed me how to do it and
what his build was and it was it was so
cool because he uses like wither horde
and then charged with light and then you
can take out the tanks and we could go
into it but it was really cool because
we reached out we started doing some
runs together and he started helping
some people in the community too and we
just kind of came to this agreement of
we're gonna have the same number of
normal runs we're gonna have the same
number here and to be honest with you
he's slowed down for me because he could
he could have taken it and I was like if
he takes it he takes it and we kind of
disagree was like I'm gonna help the
normal people out I'm gonna help the the
hard people out so we are we are tied
for number one and I don't I don't know
if he's still playing to be honest with
you because he's literally like it it
was my favorite encounter to do I don't
have a lot of time to game uh I don't
have a lot of time to do the grind
um and so it's really cool that that
encounter exists but that's that's the
way that the gentleman's agreement
worked out I just both said we're going
to help out as many people as we can
when we get to this point we're going to
stop when we're number one 1072 still
stands the test of time so the two of us
are number one on that well what for
whatever that's worth you know that's
still awesome though it's like 2 000
clears between you guys is insane first
off plus and just the fact that like you
found a that's one of those cool things
that Destiny still does is you bring
these random moments cool people you
would have never come across I have done
136 episodes with this man and I met him
at Guardian Con in line passing out
business cards because we were more
people doing that like 27 I don't
remember 2016-17 whatever it was and
then from there it's like we caught up
later you started a podcast I got yours
once which at some point
or something yeah it's like almost been
a minute
um
but those are like the little things
like and it's like yeah we're gonna give
the game a hard time it's like the
gameplay Loop is this it's a little drip
feed here but those are the moments to
stick with you and it's like when you
said yours is zero mine's whisper mine
is mine is whisper is mine because of
like my video that like the algorithm
loved for five minutes and it's just
like it and that's mine because I went
through that over and over and mine was
the exact same thing as yours because my
whisper video was it was Heavy ammo I
think it was the heavy I'm a break yeah
it was what it wasn't happening it was
like nine or 12 months after everybody
else did it and it was like you do that
point where it's like it's a fresh one
when something's broken and it's like
this is now and and that's the exact
same thing that did mine and it's just
and it feels good too to know that like
I know all these other people did it
then I did this now and it's like and
that's it's fantastic those are yeah
that's why the secret missions the
Exotic quests the dungeons those things
that they truly designed to be soloable
have some of like the special place for
me just because I love that style so
that was great stuff I I love it I love
it when they they debut because I like
to see you both you guys like you need
your content creation back because
that's your happy space like for me it's
rage right so yeah like deep Stone [__]
when people are complaining I'm like
damn this is a good raid I'm playing
this thing every week I'm just like I'm
loving the weapons I love when I'm
farming you know what I'm saying but um
I get it when it's a zero hour right
when you get that secret thing or you
get that old whisper and then it's that
dungeon I see that spot go off with e
he's like oh man you don't say Eddie's
sitting there thinking about builds for
each of the counter it's a beautiful
thing you know I'm saying that that's
them at their best and and like I said
you just hope that hopefully this season
at the very least let me ask you this
question before we go like at the very
least if we don't get uh zero Hour I was
like before you even ask that question
can I put a giant spoiler warning out
there for everybody who doesn't want to
know anything we're going to talk about
something for about five minutes so five
seconds let's go let's go and you know
what I'm talking about man out right yep
yep okay so about five minutes or so
roughly if you want to skip ahead I'll
probably wave my hands like a crazy
person when we're back
um but for now jazz hands
sorry why that sticks in my head still I
don't know
um shout out to what if the Hell movie
is that
cheerleading movie
anyway okay so five minutes five seconds
is up so some of you guys and anyone can
do this by the way so if you want to
look this is up to you you can go to the
very bottom of the bungee page and US
content creators do this and always know
where this stuff is at the press kit
it's where you find all your pictures
you see the thumbnails you see Miz be
like how do they get these crazy images
Bungie gives them to us trust me they
they have the camera angles that we
don't get
literally in the folder
artifact Battlegrounds characters gear
Hammer Helm new likes New Light Strike
and then strikes and there's one other
one in there and it's the folder is
literally called exotic Quest
so we know it's coming I'm gonna try and
put this over my face right now and it's
exactly what we thought it is the
I don't know if this is going to work
I'm gonna try and squeeze it over my
head I believe hey it kind of works it's
the best I can do
um
uh it's a weird transparency thing going
on but it's kind of there basically it
is what you guys saw the split second
image of a scream Osiris talking there
is no light here and then we have this
floating ship in an asteroid field yep
now as you also said and I think it fell
into my Discord as well we also have a
potential picture of an ornament or
whatever's coming from this as well
have you seen that
no where are you looking in the in the
in the press kit I forgot where I where
are you literally just like the season
of The Chosen prescription press kit and
then just go whether you go compressed
or large they're exactly the same it's
just exotic Quest is it key art or no
it's got to be screenshot screenshots
exotic Quest okay cool okay yeah so you
have one that just looks like the
asteroid field yeah kind of like the
long off and then the other one actually
shows the ship
yeah I see it now yeah yeah and I've
seen this it was in the trailer
says no later yeah it's gotta be bro
yeah exotic quests so that's and then
there's some data mine stuff out there
about it and this is the point where
it's like it's always exciting like
I speculated before and again this feels
like it would be perfect for like
somebody like you a timed Escape Mission
escort go in the ship of whatever's
happened because it looks like the
little scream image when you get like
the one or two frames of it it looks
like a horror movie it looks like alien
isolation it looks like an alien movie
so it's like and then there's the lore
bit we talked about it last time this is
in the game right now where kallus was
going around scooping up uh scorn in the
Tangled Shore and now it literally says
exotic Quest is this gonna be like a
timed
you know go rescue mission on a ship or
go retrieve something and get out in
time whatever it's going to be like I am
very curious when that happens what it's
going to be
like that these are the pieces of like
there may be down time in here but
whenever this Falls of course I'm gonna
lose my mind
like I said this is where we gotta admit
as death defense we can be hypocritical
crap oh they do it they reusing assets
they're not doing the restore as soon as
they give us that old content or the
content that we want
whether it be a reissue an old strike a
weapon I'm seeing people about boy shout
out to my boy from Destiny Five Guys he
just got Shadow price he's losing his
buy right now right see I'm not excited
about that one but that's just me so
it's a brief me neither I got it I did
give it to y'all do you have it yet yeah
I don't even have one yet no I don't I
only run it twice and I just ran into
get my Nightfall stuff done so I could
level my character that was it I think I
got a Feeding Frenzy
want to say Rampage some something like
this watch I got a it's a decent role
you know what I'm saying it's decent I
mean it's just it's not right here it is
right now no no I got Feeding Frenzy
thresh excuse me I'm feeling very thresh
not bad I wish the rest did a little
more more yeah trash feels like it's I
know they're like afraid of giving
people super specifically for the PVP
aspect but in PVE it doesn't feel like
it does enough it feels like a throwaway
in PVE personally I agree I I did I'm
still waiting on that because I like the
new 750s SMG from um the the Prismatic
joint
um yeah the new one yeah yeah the new
SMG is great I want to make that my one
but I'm feeling because I have one with
thresh and then I have a focus what is
this what's the um
oh uh focused fire is that what it's
called yes
last season 600 was was
um from the friction
because basically I had a friction fire
that's a Masterwork sorry about this
alone um that's Master work that was I
had like Wellspring and like a crazy
sick roll and I'm just getting my
abilities back but and I said oh well I
got thrush that's super thresh is really
you know but as good as you think it
does and I know I think yeah shout out
to Fallout plays I I think it's like it
gives you more when you have less than
half or something but then once you get
to half and it's just yeah what you're
saying no yeah just I don't even know
where I was but just I was gonna just
put the like the the pin that we're kind
of dealing with is like this whole
dungeon and then bringing stuff I think
Cognito you hit it right on the head is
as soon as they deliver like we're I
think we're so critical of the game it's
like anything it's like we're critical
of the game because we absolutely love
it we know what it can be and how good
it can be when it hits us oh when it
doesn't hit us it's like I know this
could be better yes and I I think that
the moments where Destiny is at its best
is where there's mystery anticipation
and we don't know what's coming is there
a seventh chest in the Vault of Glass
how do we get the whisper Quest lost to
light that was actually one of the
things that helped my channel back when
when I was before I took my break of
streaming
um is the the first time that we got
which it was it was whisper the Worm but
it was back in the old day which was
black spindle yes those missions mean so
much
and it they're cool moments that the
community can get after and I hope that
whatever this thing is that ship in
space is another one of those seminal
moments in the community that's like
holy crap cool let's go I like the idea
of it being a horror movie there's no
lights here and like imagine going in
and it's like the the opening of The
crota Raid where everything's pitch
black dude and you're trying to find
your way through and if you don't have a
member you've memorized your toast and
everything's gonna like oh my gosh that
would be so cool so cool it'll be so
cool because they've even let's be real
you know one thing that's pretty amazing
about
um prophecy is they played with light
and dark yeah yeah right that was the
first time I remember trying to figure
out the mechanic and we were like okay
oh would it Falls the moat falls in the
light and then it like they they started
to play with with shade and shadows this
could be an example and again like you
said you you nailed it it's like the
thing when Destiny is great is like I
said the Mysteries those Secrets when
you don't know I feel for them because
the mod Community is so you know the the
hacking's really so good at you know
getting the data whenever there's a
passion so it takes away from it but
when they do have a moment like that it
could be special the question I wanted
to ask you all though is
if we get that right
next season
is it time for Volk to come back do you
think if Vlog is not next season
um it would be a bad use of resources to
be honest yeah I'm gonna be like I've
been saying that forever like 14 the
spring season's always like worthy
question mark you had Drifter question
mark that spring season always is a bit
rough Vlog is like their their Ace in
the Hole to be like hey you've been
asking for this crap forever bam here
you go like that has to be that season
there's no way in my mind it's not
because they wouldn't do well sorry
right I was looking so they wouldn't do
season 15 like Vault of Glass which
Queen they're gonna want space in there
so I think that's the other side and I
think for me is like they're actually
starting to imagine the whole sixth
month schedule thing because if you
think about it it was essentially
prophecy dungeon came out in season of
arrivals right so that came out in
season of arrival so that was like the
summer period so maybe this season every
six months remember I talked about like
putting out like a six month content
drop and maybe they're starting to look
at that they're starting to kind of
Orient themselves in the schedule
I could see it being a new dungeon or a
new Quest or something like that this
this [__] I'm out of the asteroid belt
yeah like yeah but I mean vaulted glass
if you imagine like there's a raid here
which is deep Stone Crypt and then we
bring back the new raid the uh bring
back Vault of Glass and they do it every
six months there's just enough time for
that content that you love I was just
about to say every six months that you
can do so now we've had like a hidden
Mission I I want to say I'd like to say
that this is going to be a dungeon I
feel if it's going to be an exotic quest
line it I think it'll be cool and it
does say exotic Quest and the thing but
maybe there's another exotic Quest that
we don't know about you know because
they didn't put any of the and of course
I'm not going to spoil it here but
there's uh you know we know that that's
the Exotic Quest like it's already been
found right that whatever it is
um I hope that there is something in
addition because it does say and much
more and much more calendar and I hope
that that delivers and and more at the
at the tail end of it because that'd be
a cool way to lead into the next season
whatever it is is have that dungeon
there and instead of putting it at the
front have it at the end and you know
Season arrivals had the prophecy dungeon
at the beginning if you put it at the
end and it leads into the Vault of Glass
sometimes I'll be fine that'd be fine
now this is where I would be okay
well I was gonna say we would actually
be due for a cabal dungeon next because
we've had one of each oh yeah yeah sure
so it which makes sense so the thing is
I would be okay with you know the drip
feed stuff if we do okay we got the be
online expansion at the end of the year
right we have which would give us the
Deep Stone [__] it gives us a raid right
so it looks like rage is going to be a
once a year thing right then you
separate you put a dungeon maybe that
Following Season which is now this
season of the
um what you call seasonal where the
chosen right now
someone comes down to a Revisited
classic right which now we most likely
gonna get a vlog get the Nostalgia up
and you know listen from one thing we
know about Bungie tends to do around the
summer stuff is to get the hype going
for what's going to come towards the
fall so if you give us a vlog people's
there at the hype is up again now I can
see this could be the Cadence that
they're gonna try to hold on to until
they're actually ready for a you know
post lightfall and all that with D3 and
is it ideal is it could it be better yes
but I think they will survive with that
because as much as we say we upset as
much as we say with that new dungeon hit
that new raid hit or or let's say next
year 2022
we follow the same Cadence
and we'll see which quick what are they
gonna be taking King comes back yeah you
don't take a kick your kids fall coming
back y'all gonna be lit y'all gonna be
sending that [__] this is why this is
the best raid look at this people are
gonna go crazy to see oryx again
and this could be the little Cadence
that again to hold us down until they're
really ready for D3 until they're really
ready to release matter or whatever it
is and I I think this is the hold on
plan you know what I'm saying and we
just got it we just gotta we gotta see
what happens man we gotta see it but
I'll be honest with you that's not a bad
year bro no that's not a bad year no and
I'm excited for that that's the thing
that I think will be good is if we have
that kid yeah I have no problem with
them bringing back old assets as long as
as long as they do it in a way that
again
um rewards us for our time plays yeah
and I like the idea I think that that
was one of the reasons why Activision I
could be wrong about this but I think
Activision wanted the them to make a
destiny 3. oh actually then and then
like they would never go back to the old
stuff that Destiny one had and I like
the fact that if you can lean on the
assets without it making feeling
unrewarding like sepix is a perfect
example of it
um I think a bad example a way that they
didn't execute was having having the
moth yards in the cosmodrome to connect
that experience together
um I think that's a bad example but the
stepping strike like just absolutely
executes there's nothing wrong with
bringing a gun back in the game
especially to celebrate it but
um you're always gonna get people who
are like it's reused content but I don't
care because it's fun but if it's fun I
don't care and it's done and executed
well and like you said the key point the
the time investment is respected with
proper reward whether it be from a
weapon a loop and and a visual
perspective it's something you always
want we want to look like Gods one thing
about looking for you came out looking
yeah like oryx you you had you know what
I'm saying like that's the thing and as
long as they do that if we they'll be
okay they'll be okay because I'm telling
you right now you get a new dungeon and
you get Vlog and then you get another
rig and then you get kicks for bro you
gonna be okay
they they they lean a little bit it
would be cool if they do that for the
PVE community and then
for PVP that gives them a moment to to
to
um you know turn around and be like okay
PVP Community I know you've been
struggling a little bit here's how we're
gonna make the base Community PVP yes
like here's a couple more maps like it
would be cool if they did that and so
that the PVP Community could could be
respected and could like because I
actually think that the whole Glory
Valor system is pretty good right now we
just want some new maps
no maps all you need to do yeah a little
bit can we throw some golf balls in
there please yeah yeah
like I still want to know what they're
going to do with armor but yeah the
stinginess of infusing right now it
doesn't matter but and believe me I
agree with all the stuff you guys are
saying we want like
six months like if you do dungeon exotic
like Dungeons are better than exotic
quests yes mostly because you have
mechanics length there's more to them
I still enjoy the Exotic Quest too those
are don't quite have the same longevity
though unless you're a man no one want
to go for a thousand not everybody does
that
um but I will definitely say like will
we get Kings fall back will we get
Dreadnought the one piece that I do hope
they tie some of this stuff together as
they're finally like they're on a
narrative through line between now and
lightfall like they have a general like
they have the bullet points to get us
there
I just am really curious how in the hell
they're gonna bring Vault of Glass back
story wise with no Vault no Venus be
honest let's be honest eat a weighty the
way they brought separates back no it's
gonna be cut Bassy go connect nothing
you go just go to a virtual space and
yeah that's the case like you don't even
expect the opening encounter do you
no I don't have it it'll just block you
it'll be like
a strike yeah it's gonna be completely
not connected to anything you know I
feel like if you're gonna connect it and
if they're working on it in some way you
could do it through one of the Vex gates
in on Europa would be an easy way to do
it um and then you go in and then all of
a sudden bam you're in a new space
um I I what I'd like to see you know
what I think would be great if they want
to really help the PVE Community out you
know I love my exotic Quest or my exotic
um not quests and that's the thing is I
kind of separate outbreak from exotic
quests because I think yeah that's
different I agree I feel like secret
missions
are separate yeah those are those are
just amazing like Pinnacle level
activities that are great I and I think
that they need to lean Less on the uh
here the Exotic Quest like hey go scan
for robots and now you have Devil's
ruined I think that I think that's lame
but I understand why they did it but you
know if they could have these new
dungeons tie an exotic to the dungeon
because if you think about it there's no
real exotic that comes out of shatter
Throne pitted heresy
yeah that's right what does prophecy do
then prophecies
that's like pita heresy and those two do
have the Exotic that comes from it yeah
I was wrong about that because xenophage
is actually one of my better videos yeah
why didn't they connect those two things
together and if they're gonna do another
dungeon like have those two things kind
of connect like it would have been cool
if
um wither horde somehow was a reward or
something like that kind of quest to do
because that's really cool not only for
the content creation Community it it
gives an incentivization to people who
want to get that exotic instead of just
doing this this straight line linear I
don't like it I'm gonna be honest I I
don't like you you're absolutely right
you're absolutely like I never really
said this I'm not a fan of the
you know when they promote the season
right everybody you know new season and
then you're gonna do they tell you
you're gonna do the Exotic quest to get
blah blah blah yeah and I'm I don't like
that I I I like it when it's like
Harbinger or what it's like you know all
that stuff yeah it's a secret and then
it pops up and the the community
discovers it discovers it naturally
within the game right that's what I like
so even if they if they took out
okay in this case I probably won't say
because I like tikkus but let's just say
hypothetically you know what I'm saying
like there was a second exotic or
whatever and it's just like yo that is
put in that kind of position you know
I'm saying I prefer that then just do a
series of things and you know just like
busy work you know kill all these things
get this and then then you're gonna get
it and you hit the checklist to get an
Exotics crappy I think the way to do it
is just and I don't uh the whole reason
they make the calendar it's another one
of those they're trying to again in my
brain they're trying to get around a
problem and they're trying to sell you
on it yeah they're trying to be like yo
you're gonna get this stuff instead of
doing the calendar or whatever I think
you just say these are the things you're
gonna get and then have question marks
and be like two exotic quests I know it
doesn't feel I don't know to a marketing
person it doesn't work but to a human
being it does because they're like wait
what is it what is this where exotic is
that going to be is that gonna be is
that gonna be outbreak is that gonna be
is that going to be a hawk moon is
they're going to be is there going to be
Icebreaker is Icebreaker yeah I know
never on that one but yeah but if you're
like hey by the way you're gonna get
this bow and then you're gonna get this
this other gun and we already know what
it is so we're kind of like oh like that
anticipation like the payoff of all the
movies and stuff like that when you ever
go to a movie when you have that moment
where it turns I mean let's go back
spoiler alert for like 40 years ago you
know the reason why Empire Strikes Back
and Star Wars hits so hard is spoiler
alert if you haven't seen it what's
wrong with you yes when Darth Vader like
reveals it and says Luke I'm your father
that's the moment we're like oh what
what and like if you have those moments
in the game that anticipation pays off
and that's right you're right there Cog
is is just like that's what we need more
of I don't mind them being like here's
the basic activity you're gonna do but
if you can build anticipation it doesn't
feel good to people who are in marketing
because in marketing it's like hey we
really want to sell you on this but
sometimes just selling the mystery yeah
can feel good breach even even if we'll
see what would help e you just nailed it
is that he looks at that that road that
road map he's like
three play Battlegrounds yeah no I mean
I know on the season page that says text
mechanica redacted or it's a Tex
mechanic redacted exotic quests so in my
mind I know there's something to look
forward to so I know that's there no I
know but even but to what Mano is saying
which is a good point which is like
having that having something on the map
even if it's like a silhouette and it's
darking and it's like right you know you
just so do you want to know when is that
what you're saying you want to know when
it's coming I just don't know you don't
necessarily have to put when you can
literally put that underneath the
imagery right yeah and you can say boom
boom boom like even you know what I
thought was a good job even though you
know yeah I thought it was a good season
thought remember when we all in our mind
new trials are gonna come back but it
was like we was like yo what's Imperium
found remember we were sitting there
coming out with Theory you you gotta
sell it you gotta sell the mystery like
mine was 100 right and this way people
like yo when when this week happens or
when towards this part of the Season you
all week Something's Cooking like yeah
you get people to log it like that they
they they're very good at mystery that's
their strength but they have to also in
the market yeah when they do it yeah but
they also have to Market it to give us
that anticipation okay this season is
not as basic as we dig this still some
stuff cooking and they can do a better
job but I do agree they have to do a
better job of it like I that I think
that they try to sell us on this
schedule too much and I think that if
they take that schedule away and be like
there's gonna be stuff that you can
check in with you know it's like selling
a product you know you don't want to
sell like hey here's some coke like
here's some Coca-Cola it's the same
Coca-Cola you've always had right very
different Coke
all right
into a Cadence now and we're going at
about 400 beats per minute everybody
ready here we go
Mr Destra my heart feels like it's going
to stop
don't let it stop you all right but um I
think that they try too much to sell us
on this schedule and I think that
there's actually some marketers it feels
good but if you remove it it could I
just feel like they're marketing it the
wrong way they I feel like their trailer
team does such a good job just like put
it out and be like here's the stuff
we're gonna like here's the basic
overview of the Season we're not
touching the schedule you show up when
you wanna because like here this feels
like a checklist it's like okay I gotta
go to work to do my iron Banner on
February 23rd write it in okay oh yeah
Guardian game starts here there is a
little bit of like is Sparrow Racing
League gonna come back I I hope it at
least but doubt hope would know I hope
that they do I don't think that they
will because hopefully they're using
their resources for other things unless
if they somehow make it like Bare Bones
I highly highly doubt it but guard games
I feel like last season two or last year
wasn't as solid because again there was
no anticipation it was just Titan
Mobility spam and Titans still have the
best ability spam in the game they they
just do it's just they're gonna win if
you're gonna base it on ability spam
instead of like activities completed or
other things like that they're gonna
have to redo that
um but why I mean just say these are the
things that are coming and don't put a
date so that it feels more I know it
feels more mysterious but more you're
more likely to instead of being like
well I need to be this level at this at
this section I'll just play the game
until it feels good instead of here's my
checklist I'm done sure well I mean even
the idea of like content creation
unknown hype things like that like a
weekly reset video doesn't even matter
anymore most of the time because they'll
tell you the stuff before you've got a
scheduled Cadence of when things are
going to come you know when it's off
weeks and then finally there's good if
something does happen
stuff explodes and then like okay yeah
there's something to check in for
otherwise you know what if it was just
like this season we've got Guardian
Games we'll have you know Battlegrounds
that are dispersed out maybe it's like
you know they'll figure out how those
fall and then on the other side if they
could like get away from such like the
predictive calendar to also make sure
that when you do check in you're not so
hampered by the weekly like must yeah
like you're not the prisoner to the
seasonal challenges it's got to be the
combination of both because right now
it's like week week check check check
check check later on if it's like oh
cool I checked in here got a couple
Battlegrounds this is pretty fun I
worked on some stuff cool come back
later oh we got some more stuff in
there's they need a little more
flexibility in there for all of us so if
you want to grind you can you don't have
to come here but then still pepper stuff
and drop it throughout because we got
two and a granted like their worry I
guess is like
if they drop one Battleground you gotta
run the same Battleground over and over
for a week that gets boring but if they
drop all four
that's different too I don't know that's
but yes I'm with you guys on less of all
right let me pencil at the next three
months of Destiny right that I don't
want to do
let's see man and I think that they're
trying to do it to be you know
transparent but they're they're right
there's
you can walk you can walk and chew gum
at the same time like there's a way for
you to be mysterious but at the same
time like how people feel like their
purchase which I I'm gonna say this and
this I hope they'll turn some people off
let's go I don't like people who are
like 10 bucks for rehast rehashed stuff
and this is all the same like
you can't even go see a movie for two
hours for ten dollars well you can't see
a movie at all right now
but I mean if you think about it like
you can get a Netflix monthly
subscription one month of content for 12
bucks they're giving it to you for 10
bucks and people who are like I'm not
gonna invest in the season because I'm
broke if you don't have ten dollars like
go shovel a driveway like don't mow
along
like
I have some people who stop and they're
like I'm 14 and I don't have any money
I'm like well first of all go shovel
someone's like that's how I made money
when I was in kids
yeah it's like 10 bucks and I feel like
more people put Roblox in their way
because at the end of the day you're
still spending money on something like
you're gonna go get like a cookie at
lunch or something like that and
nowadays it's probably like two bucks
but like you're saying that
all this content that they're giving us
isn't worth a two hour movie less than a
two-hour movie and I that that just
that's cognitive
because I get a lot of the community
who's like it's just too much money it's
like 10 bucks
the seasons in Destiny give more than
probably anything else any other game
that I could think of in a season I
can't picture one that gives as much
yeah weapons content variety story voice
record lines
I honestly don't know what values that
the thing that bugs me is when so much
of the community is like I've wasted so
much money on this game and I look at
the amount of time that I have spent
with this game not only because I'm a
content creator but just be from the
pure enjoyable ability of the plane in
the core Loops yeah it's not all great
all the time but I mean have you looked
at the Netflix library now like
three-fourths of it is not great stuff
like
I am it is a bargain it is pennies to
the dollar for those people who want to
like go see a movie which all those
things are like oh I'll go see a movie
or I want to you know do these things
ten dollars is a market compared to the
other stuff that we've got so
week four week eight week 12 the fact
that you have like probably a couple
good solid weeks like three different
times where you'd get like hey let me
catch up on the season now I can jump in
I can see all the new Battlegrounds
couple strikes are back
yeah I was like I do I give it a hard
time because we live in it for sure
right
um but again when you sit there and I
went through and I did the exact same
thing I was like I know I'm breaking
this down but I also made a list of like
everything in season 13 I was like holy
it's actually a big list of items again
it's just 10 bucks so it's all
perspective too it's just like we live
in this thing so I'm like well it is
only one Battleground every week and I'm
also going like I'm probably lucky we
get one Battleground every week just to
start like yeah it's it's all good to
take a humble pill every so often be
like yeah it's not so bad yeah listen I
I again you guys say the best
I struggled but I see or hear you know
I've wasted money in this game and you
know they're disrespecting me and you
know with this content and it's real and
I look at these people's hours played in
this game yeah and I'm like how dare you
that that is literally the equivalent
of eating all the food in the house
and refrigerate you'll say every day
you're in this refrigerator it keep
giving me this recycle you don't have to
eat fair you don't have to partake like
because clearly you're indulging
yourself you are in the so that that's
the thing that I struggle with it's like
I I am literally playing hours upon
hours of this game is this game perfect
no is there things that could be fixed
yes we know that but it's just this when
we have the insane amount we have an
abnormal amount of time investment with
this one game I have never seen a game
and I've been gaming a long time
where I've played one game
for over six years yeah one name and a
besides wow
an anomaly yeah but that's the key is
there are two I'm literally putting two
on the list of like how many games have
you spend hours in World of Warcraft and
that is it like and I went from one
little hardcore dedicated and somehow
it's still another MMO but light right
either way but yeah it's like how much
do you get out of those and it's just
that's all I'm saying it's to me it's
disrespectful when I hear people say
this was a waste of money and they were
bro take your hours back stop let's look
at all your hours and let's equate that
as far as time investment and financial
output I actually you actually did that
like so let's just say let's because
this is the argument and I'll say this
down with a podcast and I say this on my
stream all the time let's say you bought
like the expansion for Beyond light and
you bought be online that's it let's say
you spent a hundred dollars dollars if
you spend 500 hours in the game which is
nothing
it's nothing in the game nothing my
hours are probably like I don't even
know I don't even know time and Destiny
I don't have to look yeah I'm sure this
would probably be scary I played a lot
of this game but I placed a lot of the
other games too but if you look at it if
you play 500 hours of the game and you
spent a hundred dollars that's 20 cents
an hour
you cannot get that amount of time
out of anything anymore huge except for
like I'm gonna go on a walk in like
I'm gonna walk to California maybe yeah
no the only thing else I wanted to say
on this is we're probably kind of like
wrap it up obviously time as well but
um the one thing for all of this as well
it's like the value we get the things
we're hoping for this the pacing of
seasons and all that stuff the one thing
that Destiny does like neat bungee
especially for Destiny needs to remember
is
when they talk to the Diablo developers
they've done this before and it's like
people are going to leave your game good
bad other times a lot of content little
content it's how they feel when they
leave that matters yes I was like and
that's one of the because nobody's gonna
play this forever I take little breaks
you take some life happens what's the
last taste in your mouth
if somebody jumps into the season plays
a couple weeks and they're like oh I
can't even finish out the war table for
like seven weeks I'm just like
those are just the little things to
consider of like how much as you guys
said we describe like we're being held
prisoner by a game that's not a great
analogy
it's not I feel that way but you feel
that way yeah but and that's the thing
it's like so those are the balance of
like and again it's a delicate line that
they're trying to walk of like how much
to give and how to sell it and Market it
and put business and keep food on the
table for however many developers they
haven't done anything and the pandemic
and they're working from home absolutely
absolutely I get all of that but again
it's like
where they set these pieces because
people are gonna leave at some point you
have people like mtashed at some point
he's just absolutely blown up and he's
just like this is one of his first one
he stepped away he's like some stuff
looks cool other people live in it some
people are going to come and go some
people are going to see something like
outriders go and then decide if they
want to come back there's all these
little pieces and it's just trying to
make sure they don't leave too much of
that prisoner feel
right to make sure that like yeah that
was pretty fun I took a little break
from it but hey there's a new season
looks kind of cool I heard an awesome
the internet exploded with this Destiny
thing let me go see what it's all about
and that's just the one thing I want
them to try and think about is like if I
look at something and I'm like oh and I
dread what's coming that that worries me
love when like I'm gonna do it anyway
because I'm a content creator but if
somebody's like hey I got the season
seen some Battlegrounds cool you told me
this is gonna ha I'll see you later like
yeah that's what you don't want and
that's just the thing to watch out for
yeah that's it and it's okay I tell
people all the time it's okay like if
you if this season or a specific season
ain't hitting for you it's okay man just
take a break do something else get your
backlog knocked out and in this other
situations like a skill up where he took
a break and now he came back and he's
like yo like I'm enjoying myself you
know what I'm saying it's okay you know
say it's gonna be here but again we
gotta the people who are struggling like
you know lashing out and oh they got to
get rid of Luke Smith and cancel this
guy yeah
can I just speak to that by the way
because everyone who's like cancel Luke
Smith they need to get their head
examined because Luke Smith is
responsible for the best times in
Destiny period period fall to Glass the
Vault of Glass taking care King's fall
yeah like arguably when all and I think
that I think he even skill up said
something about this if you think about
like the whole looter shooter genre No
Game No game has hit has hit or been as
successful successful with all its
problems as Destiny has Anthem pretty
much dead probably next time
and then Avengers was supposed to do it
was supposed to be that next thing came
out Half Baked I know it bought this you
played some of that too
um I know that my my buddy damn it to
hell was a huge uh Borderlands guy
Borderlands 3. that game's pretty much
toast now I know that division is
moments right but and now they're
apparently going to come out with
something they're going to come out with
some new content I heard violent but
there let's be real like they crashed
and burned hard yeah right now like you
know they just got a 60 frames per
second pass but they didn't even listen
to their Community they they there is no
back and forth with the division twab
it's this is what it's going to be and
that's it and deal with it like their
community base was very upset with the
raid and everything you know yeah so
yeah I agree I agree so like I just
think that people have to
trust that Luke Smith knows what he's
doing and again I think it comes back to
Luke is being not disingenuous he's
trying to put something behind the
curtain right no it's like you know it's
exactly I talked about like there's
never gonna be a destiny 3. we know that
Luke Smith lies he said the stranger
ain't coming back we're done with that
storyline be online what's the first
thing we see by the way the stranger's
back Hulk Moon's not gonna have damage
increase remember that yeah yeah
well yeah he's trying to make
expectations he's trying to create that
mystery he's got the right idea it's
just did the systems execute it and no
matter what we love the game because of
all the feelings we get from it so I
think that the people who say that we
need to get rid of Luke Smith I think
that's a bad they don't understand
what's really going on do they need to
fix the stuff that's going on with PVP
yeah yeah but I mean I don't feel like
it's that crazy it's just a resource
allocation thing I just Cog I love I
didn't even think of that I love that I
have this much water I got to put out
which fires like I love that yeah that's
a spot on man
spot on brother thank you we all know
what's going on man like I said you just
have some fun enjoy it don't take too
serious and uh like I said get
frustrated step away these all these
great games too to play and come back
with your batteries recharge and refresh
you're good to go
yeah well I would definitely say we have
um oh yeah we yeah we have definitely
filled out a full podcast tonight
three hours for a little over three uh
yes
but for your sake for cogs for all of us
it has been
somehow a fantastic are you saying no 12
the 12 is light the only thing I
definitely want to say on the 12th
Dakota's killing this is she's like
you're getting not the 12 there's no 12.
there's the Cowboys we have a new season
now we'll see there's not no 12. yeah
definitely like the the yeah
yeah some powerful stuff to do you want
a ticket no no no okay
um
so black at Bungie was introduced last
year and they had the bee herd
collectible pin last year was
not fun for many reasons
but the like visual like seeing in the
news the world of everything we saw like
what rate like how much racism has come
to the Forefront is really really really
sad
um Bungie of course one of like leaders
in the game development world of doing
the right things socially helping the
right causes and always trying to do
good things
um
last year there be heard the collectible
bin for black lives matter
they uh they donated to the Equal
justice initiative added up to about 425
from that pin so to all of those of you
who bought that who haven't seen it yet
I think I have multiple of those things
now because every so often I'll just
like is it back in stock so I can buy
another one
um and then that's the other side is
pride as well that like they do the
bungee Foundation the bungee store
basically they keep almost none of their
profits
they're a game developer that has like
one of the best social consciences and
they're also not afraid to stand up for
the right thing when you see the CEO
in the protest marching next to them
exactly yeah like it's it's impressive
yeah and that was one of those things
too it's like I summed up the
twab this week on my Twitter and the
first thing I basically just said was
like black lives have should and will
always matter and that was one of those
pieces I was like the twab didn't have
much but that's the most important part
of the entire thing yeah that was the
big one yeah you know for me it's
important to see because like you know
as a black male it's it's one of those
things that um
I always feel like when some injustice
happens like in the moment it's cool to
see everyone come together right it's
cool to see everyone fight for what's
right but what I like what Bungie is
doing is
you want to say the initial emotion of
the moment has since passed right
and that you know hashtag this has kind
of calmed down yeah but the black
squares have faded away right exactly
but you're still seeing them talk about
it you still seeing and that to me
resonates even more because it's cool to
do something when it's trending the
moment corporations want to get behind
something and it's cute in the moment
but once the moment has passed are you
going to keep that same level of energy
are you going to be consistent with that
message and to see them do that kudos to
Bungie like I said like I said we love
this game man it's one of the best
communities you know um inclusive
doesn't matter your race ethnicity
sexuality religion it does not matter
you know at the end of the day just
treat people decent human decency which
should come to the Forefront and as a
result you know what I'm saying as this
great Community obviously he met you at
the you know at a convention because of
this game so like I said there's nothing
anybody's really gonna tell me about
Destiny Bungie as a company you know
it's one of my absolute favorites
through the ups and downs good people
good leadership and a good message so
salute to them on this this was cool to
see and I I like I like to see stuff
like that from from all companies
honestly not just Bungie yeah so I mean
like the twab was still there but it was
like it's such a new season but it's
cool I mean I live in Minnesota pretty
close to Minneapolis St Paul so it's
cool to see a lot of that activism and
stuff starting to happen because like
it's hitting us home because like most
people in Minnesota to be honest with
you like we feel like everyone kind of
just like everyone gets along but like
that moment last year uh you know oh
yeah that was such a moment for us as
minnesotans to be like yo and now it's
exposed a lot of stuff that actually has
been you know festering so it's cool to
see a company that's getting in front of
it and we don't we want to make sure
that we value everybody who who is part
of their world and like I don't I don't
like with people are like there's no
twab there's nothing necessarily in the
game because there's such a fresh season
but to see them step up and be like yo
this is this thing you know this is this
is a huge movement and we want to make
sure that we continue to do that so
um you know that that is very cool to
see from a gaming company that is not
only just speaking about what's going on
in the game that's how you build
relationships too yes that's how you
build relationships with your
communities you step step up and you
know are strong for everyone Absolutely
I'll say it well said good stuff
I was like I don't think I've got
anything else to cover besides that but
I definitely didn't want to end without
that one for sure no absolutely cool
um
well sir Mano I knew I knew we were
gonna have a lot to talk about I thought
it might be a lengthy podcast we lived
up to say the least we've had our ones
where like we have so much to cover and
we like Barrel through now we spent an
hour just getting to it so oh yeah but
it's honestly a black like I've I've
known you off and on through content and
Twitter and so many things for so long
it's so awesome to like just chat with
you for a while because normally like
I'm streaming you're streaming we rate
each other's streams sometimes we rate
each other at the wrong time which is
still hilarious because we've had that a
couple of times I read and you're like I
was just
it's like it's fine it's cool it's but
um no it's like much respect just
everything that you've done uh very
happy to have you on and seriously it
was an absolute pleasure as we wrap up
the show we definitely want to let
people know
uh like you know where you can find you
anything you got cooking cool anything
you got planned any like getting back
into things just like what all is going
on in your world and what they can
expect and where to find you because now
the floor is yours well it's always like
awesome to talk with people who are as
passionate about this game and Cognito
we've never really chatted but I started
talking to YouTube absolutely brother it
was cool vibing with you and just
chatting and talking about that yeah
about this it's been a pleasure so thank
you for having me on I do appreciate I
know you've been trying to get me on for
a little bit but you know we have to you
know you schedule other people out and
then we have technology issues but no
it's it's just a testament to the great
people who are here
um on my side of things
um I do a lot of PVE help I'm actually
hoping to start maybe getting better at
the whole PVP thing and maybe start
doing some trials things cool the big
thing the big thing that I've been I've
been doing lately and I have to put this
up on YouTube I need to get a video
editor is undercover lfgs which are and
I'll explain this because I know you had
mentioned it so what I'm doing
it's a cool thing because Marco style
kind of does it a little bit but I
wanted to go and see how good people who
are in lfg's actually who say that
they're Sherpas how good are they so
I'll go in and I'll put on the old I'll
put on the old aviators
and be like yo so here's what we're
gonna do and so then I'll actually talk
about it and I go in and I act like I'm
this kid I'm like this like maybe middle
school high school kid and I have a
voice changer on the go XLR it's kind of
a little bit of the um uh I forget the
guy's name the kit Boga guy like he
comes in he tries to be a different
person and we actually see what it is
and so we've run the range of people who
should like people who say that they're
Sherpas and they don't really teach up
to a person my my most impressive one
and I'd love to put this on YouTube it's
the sherpa you want to get we got this
guy who's like legit like I hopped in it
was Last Wish and God you're gonna love
this let's go a sherpa for Last Wish I
was like cool so and he's like yeah most
people skip the last encounter and like
how to do Riven we're gonna teach you
how to do Riven legit
and he like we almost we almost got
there but he just said hey how's
everyone's time looking like yeah yeah
how's everyone's time looking at people
could we just go through it and we could
we just blast through it like at the end
I actually revealed it and it was a huge
moment for him because it was like yo so
I gave him like a soundtrack and stuff
like that but that's something that I've
been doing recently awesome that's
awesome and it's it's cool just to see
the people who are awesome trying to
help in the community but it's also
funny to also see the people who save at
their Sherpas
yeah if you've if you've done a little
bit of LFC you've probably had some
experiences yeah but I have had some
pretty salt like you guys were awesome
nice helpful and I'm like hey I don't
raid that often I'm usually able to kind
of carry my own
um but it's just the ones you when you
get the spectrum of what you just went
through and you said well last I was
trying to do it like I want to show you
how to do it for real that is a short
list of people that's impressive you
haven't found that unicorn in Haystack
so oh absolutely and I I want to shout
out real quick too because we're on the
same level my man back forget if he's in
there and uh he he joined the clan maybe
about a year and a half two years ago
and like he has been a godsend for
sharper you know as far as getting
completely green people never done a
raid before in their life and then
pulling them through and it's just cool
to see and then that you see the fever
start for uh for for Destiny you know
what I'm saying and you see I'm like all
right it's cool but yeah great great
Point man I like that concept that's
cool yeah so anyway that's uh one thing
I'm doing plus you know lots of PVE and
another helps part of the thing that's
that's a schedule thing for me I'm
trying not to do too much but it's just
we're getting back to full-time teaching
so like instead of doing this hybrid
schedule like I'm doing the scheduler I
see some of the kids one day it looks
like we're gonna go back to like full
time so like my full-time band director
job's gonna kind of Kick Back again so
I'm going to be less and less you know
available to do stuff so I'm kind of
working that out but
um you can find me at twitch.tv slash
Mana duster77 or on Twitter at the
manodestra
um I would love to get the manodestra or
just manodestra on Twitter or all these
other things I'm waiting for the name
availability availability to kick in
um but um that's my my big Jam is
helping people raids uh if the dungeons
if there's a new dungeon I'm telling you
I'm gonna be right there Harbinger doing
those things too that's that's where
I'll be and uh yeah just vibing on the
game when I get time and go from there
cannot wait for cross play for sure
thing oh yeah yeah
you're streaming be like just join my
game session and I could help anybody oh
yeah it would be awesome that would be
so nice so no you cannot cannot wait to
see everything you do because honestly
the fact I mean shout out like do it all
this bad everything else Andy or twitch
partner now like you have been killing I
don't know how much sleep you get but
you've been killing it
I wish I got more yeah everybody's I was
like what do you do I'm a band director
I'm a destiny content creator I'm a
streamer and I have tape on my eyelids
to try and do all this stuff at the same
time yeah yeah man if I had a family I
would not be able to do it so
that's it's cool but again thank you
guys for having me on it's been an
awesome it's been awesome just chat
about it we hit a lot of really good
stuff so yeah it's been awesome man
didn't actually hit as deep on this like
going through the bullets of the Season
as I thought we just kind of roundabout
got to him so it was good
what do you got anything's fancy coming
up for the weekend
not the um halftime show I'm talking
about either
buddy
[Laughter]
your first one shout out to man oh man
for coming through you know saying
obviously great great perspectives a lot
of passion love the takes you know what
I'm saying I love what you're doing out
there in the community really cool stuff
and first time got a chance to interact
with you so this was all this was very
cool very cool so salute to you yeah
definitely a fun show the tangents were
great
um yeah man you know me at Lord Cognito
on Twitter uh come check us out on
Sunday Ironwood podcast it will be the
Lord's day we're gonna have an old
veteran returning Eric's gaming
really holy cow is he coming back yeah
he'll be on a Sunday or 1 p.m Eastern
check us out on YouTube one or two other
times yeah I've had he's been like it's
been a while since he's been on it's
probably been like a year I think I had
last time you were on one time when I
had him on the first time I like popped
in for a little bit because you guys
were talking yeah probably Destiny or
something at one point yeah so it's
gonna be funny because the last time the
last time we had him on Anthem had was
about to come out now
and that's that's how long that's why
it's so funny because I give you a
little bit because that's a yeah what
the top is going to be like yeah so
about this potential cancellation so
come check us out we're gonna have some
cool gaming topics it'll be fun in the
realm and I just want to also I got the
Hat on today but yo thank everyone for
the support of Lords of gaming.net it
really means a lot with uh the writers
that we have have really been killing it
man fantastic topics there's a great um
what you call this a great article right
now that got up about Assassin's Creed
they've lost its identity it's it's
really a lot of people have a they'll
it's it's it's a debate right now like
it's a big thing all because of this
article so again we appreciate the
retweets whatever you see something onto
gaming.net on their Twitter account to
log that Twitter account and you guys
share it it means a lot to us we're
really doing well and uh oh I put this
out in the universe because I've been
meaning to say this well if anyone's
interested in uh you know writing about
their favorite game of ours that Destiny
please contact me I'm looking for um
definitely someone who is passionate
about writing about Destiny and maybe
what it doesn't have to be new stuff but
if they're just interested in the game
and making something about it just
please reach out to me I am looking for
that I would like to get a little bit
more flavor of that but that's all I got
man and uh of course that last word with
e we back at it again you know what I'm
saying it was good show as always and I
love the uh content you put out so the
uh the the the the keep it simple stupid
for me
like now granted I'm long-winded I know
it so it's like for me to do something
Short's not gonna be but to truly like
the feedback on those videos has been
good because like yeah there's 30 minute
videos to break down leveling for new
players and all but I got time stamps
but then there were Caster the hammer
the table the
umbrella and grams I'm like Jesus
there's a lot to go through so no I'm
glad some people have been enjoying that
hopefully it does
it may not be the biggest video but if
some people understand the season better
then cool I helped so that's the goal
yeah and that's what you'll find
everyone he is literally just on the
YouTube channel uh obviously going to be
covering Destiny we know it's going to
be heavy but Destiny right now but I'm
still working through Immortals Phoenix
Rising so I'll probably get back to that
one day uh we know outriders gonna be
doing some preview coverage for that the
demo will be the 21st so I'll be hitting
that yes and then April 1st will be of
course the big release so that actually
seems to fall at a quiet time for
Destiny which is good but I'm totally
fine with that so you can look forward
to that stuff from me
um so twitch Twitter Youtube streaming
on both now kind of going back and forth
about to turn on the channel memberships
on YouTube as well so just trying to get
all the cogs going at this point and
then still kickboxing on the side so
I'm gonna throw this because we're not
doing any Fitness stuff today just
because I'm gonna call that now so don't
even try and redeem any points but
shuttle down yeah oh oh oh oh oh oh what
exclusive we getting look behind me
oh
we get oh we about to get an instruction
okay okay okay it's on now we're gonna
we're gonna get those kicks those four
oh okay okay
hold on hold on hold on did that animal
just like literally just was there an
animal back there no there's nothing I
thought I saw like a cat back there and
then you just like kicked the crud out
of that thing and I was like that animal
didn't even move because he just said
some time no I don't know
oh we gave that kickboxing instruction
that way oh yeah
save them save that for your future I
don't even know how many points that
one's gonna cost you guys but it's gonna
be a lot when did you get that I've had
that for a while so that's from my work
actually when we switched uh Brands I
bought the I brought that one home and
it's been upstairs at our workout room
but we rearranged some stuff because my
wife's desk was back there as you guys
know yes
um
but we switched to move some things
around so now this is hanging out down
here in this room so
Dakota you're dreaming if you think it's
just 10K there's gonna be more some of
you guys have more Channel points
virtual kickboxing class with ubuntus
yeah so just to tease that one for some
random future time but for now just the
push-ups and setups we'll leave it at
that
yeah honestly like even like Super Mario
3D World came out today and honestly we
really want to play that a little bit so
we'll see if I get that on my switch
because if you haven't played Super
Mario 3D World honestly one of the best
Marios I've played in ages it was
excellent on Wii U so
uh other than that man Mano pleasure a
blast you're welcome back anytime
because obviously we can talk to crap
about this game because we played too
much so but yeah I know you'll be busy
with the band director stuff so you know
get the get the Cadence of your downtime
find us and we'll get you in sounds
pretty bad yeah you just let me know I'm
always down it's been a pleasure
appreciate it absolutely absolutely all
right well uh thank you guys in chat you
guys have been awesome to put up with
the technical difficulties if you want
the middle stuff that we talked through
uh it'll be on my YouTube channel iron
Lords had podcast YouTube channel iTunes
Spotify pretty much anywhere you can
find it uh that will be definitely out
there everywhere and edited in full and
then for this episode uh February 12th
man it's been awesome Cog of course
enjoy your weekend with the
excellentgester.com and go check out the
iron Lords podcast Channel but for
tonight the long episode we wrap it up
episode number 136 for February 12th it
has been
the last last word